Welcome back, Master and Miss!
I am once again eating my dinner.
Hello everybody!
I'm back!
Welcome back!
We may be made in this, but we are made full!
Thank you guys!
Thank you!
Good morning!
Mint gaming!
It's mint gaming!
What am I eating today?
I'm eating chicken and rice once again.
And once again, eating chicken and rice!
I meant
I found four kittens in a storm drain near my house.
What do they...
What do...
What do they look healthy and are so so so cute?
Keep.
Four kittens?
That's a lot though.
That's a lot.
Chicken is appropriate considering the game.
So true!
We went to the chicken kitchen, didn't we?
Chicken kitchen chicken!
No.
Sounds healthy.
Unless it's karaage.
It's not karaage.
I'm kind of healthy sometimes.
I'm kind of healthy.
Howdy howdy.
Hope you're well.
Detect the phantoms.
Wait, getting...
Wait, getting news.
This may not be the plot.
Thanks for the super chat!
I wonder what this buy and send button does.
You might want to check your bank account.
I think that'll answer it.
I think.
Maybe.
Mmm, karaage.
Yeah, now I'm thinking about karaage.
Fried chicken.
Yummy!
Welcome back to ghost trick.
I kind of want to just get into it today, if that's OK.
I kind of want to just dive right on in.
So we can start doing some ghost tricks and tips and tricks.
What was I going to say though?
Oh, I was going to do a recap.
Did you hear that?
Made Momoi and Midori are going to be playable.
They're going to be playable!
Have fun ghost drinking.
I did not hear that.
Made Momoi and Midori.
I will get them both.
Goodbye.
Goodbye jimmies.
Eat the nummy mouth food with your mouth using mouth food eating techniques that have been passed down through the generations.
Like onto mouth food eating techniques that get passed down.
That was certainly a sentence.
That's just Yoko.
He's always like that.
True.
I mean, eating has been passed down, right?
Also, oh my gosh.
Garlamal, thank you for the akasimpa before the stream started.
Thank you so much.
Sorry, I have to like lean over to get my food.
Because of the way my desk is.
Where did we... I know where we left off on.
But I'm trying to think of what... Okay, so...
Oh, we started with the execution.
And we had to turn the power off.
And we had to get our... get the Chad man in a very stealthy sequence.
OMG, the bank just charged me.
Lamal, Lamal, Lamal, get charged, get charged, get charged.
Chad Jowd.
Yes, Detective Jowd.
And...
And we watched a guy gulp down a bunch of pills.
Yes, that happened too.
Yes, yes, yes.
So we got him through the jail.
Jailbreak, baby.
And then we... but then he got caught.
It was all for nothing.
He got caught by Elvis Detective.
Did Lin die again?
I don't think she did.
I just finished catching up to your previous ghost trick streams.
I'm right on time.
Let's go.
Thank you so much for watching them.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you.
Silly boy, welcome to membership.
And...
So then, after that happened, after we got him out...
Lin went to the commissioner guy to say, stop his execution.
But we realized the reason he's going through with the execution...
Baby Cortex for the five gifted.
Thank you so much.
The reason he's going through with the execution is because his daughter has been kidnapped by the hot blue lady.
Yippee.
Yeah, blue lady.
So we ended off on...
But actually, the daughter wasn't kidnapped.
She was just a hot lady.
As a ghost, what's it feel like when you encounter Ofuda Oshide?
As a ghost, I feel nothing.
Every day.
I feel nothing.
What was I going to say?
Oh!
And...
Oh yeah, we're now checking out the hot blue lady.
So I'm excited for this part.
So we're challenges.
Oh wait, just kidding.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I was under extras.
We're under continue.
How's the audio?
I think the main menu is a little quiet.
But...
Yeah, see the autosave.
We're at 1210 AM.
Oh yeah, we did save the commissioner's life by giving him his meds.
He went...
He...
He coped those down.
He was used to that.
He's a...
Yeah.
But yeah, let's go back into the autosave.
Let's just get right into it, baby.
I wonder if I should turn DVR off for this.
So people coming in can just kind of watch.
1210 AM.
The justice minister's daughter has been abducted.
The kidnappers demand the execution of the death row prisoner Zhao to be carried out tonight.
Yes, this is a good recap.
She's so hot.
Oh ma'am.
Even your silhouette.
Look at the way she just...
Just power sits.
I've never seen a power sit before like that.
Lin says the execution is a mistake and I believe her.
So I'm paying the kidnappers hideout a visit to see what I can find out about the abduction.
Yeah, that's a practice sit.
I want to be that chair.
Mike Tyson!
Thanks for the vibe, Captain.
You did.
What took you so long?
Who's here?
Oh, my goodness.
Your instinct was right, beauty, my dear.
Not this.
Not this guy.
They had that restaurant surrounded.
It took me forever to shake them.
And now my poor bike is ready for the scrap heap.
Not Shaggy.
I forgot about the voice.
It fits him though, doesn't it?
Oh, next time.
Maybe you should...
Oh, no.
I can't.
I can't be high.
I can't do it.
Next time.
Maybe you should make it a tricycle so you don't hurt yourself.
Ouch, that hurts, beauty.
But that's okay.
That's what I love about you.
I can't un-hear Shaggy.
I'm doing the voice.
I'm doing the voice and I can't un-hear Shaggy.
Ba-bum.
Du-duh-duh-duh-duh-duh, Happy birthday!
Be a little more gentle with our valuable hot seat.
Wait, is she in the box?
I have to voice them.
Thanks, I think?
You are truly Minto... Minto-minded.
Minto-minded, Minto-minded.
Pet girls!
Welcome to the membership, thank you so much!
Yes, a wry smile.
I'm going out for a breath of fresh air.
You're on guard duty.
Alright, I'll dream of you until you return.
Why don't you open the trunk for our...
guest.
I will, beauty.
I was just taking a little breather.
So when I asked for sultry Minto a while back, this was it.
Also...
I am going to turn up the sounds just a little bit.
Maybe like that.
Sorry, I just don't want to be... I know I do this every time.
Ciao!
Thanks for the gifting!
All right, little lady.
Let me open that trunk for you.
Oh, okay.
Oh, is he actually going to fall asleep?
Beauty!
Oh wait, there was a birthday party here.
What, because there's like streamers and then there's a birthday cake?
Looks like the Justice Minister's daughter really has been kidnapped.
Something else is bothering me too.
Wait, if we go back to their house though...
I don't think I've ever been to this room before.
But something about it is giving me a strange sense of deja vu.
I've seen something like this before.
Yes, this is just like the room in the... that Lin got killed in.
I'll let you guess which one.
Trick time, trick time, trick time.
Taking something... Oh.
Okay, I want to bring something up that someone...
One big streamer on... Am I too big?
Here, I'll make myself small.
Sorry, am I too big?
So, last time I played I got... I saw like a comment from someone.
That said that they were kind of sad that...
I was skipping some of the funniest dialogue because...
Because I was trying not to get hints for the puzzles.
And while I understand...
That, you know, sometimes there might be stuff that I miss in general.
You know...
I'll do better about... You know what?
I won't care so much about the hint stuff so much this time.
If anything, not big enough.
Thank you for the first ever super time.
Thank you.
Thanks, eventual ghosts.
But...
So...
But also, I...
You know...
And sometimes in games like this, there might be stuff that I miss.
So...
That's just kind of the nature of these types of games maybe.
Sometimes you miss dialogue.
So...
Some of the funny dialogue is in the word bubbles.
Yeah, so...
I'll do my best to...
To hit them.
But sometimes I might forget, so...
Yeah.
Sorry if I do.
Okay.
That's all I wanted to talk about since I got reminded because of the bubble.
Taking something precious to manipulate others.
So that's what kidnapping is.
I guess...
But doesn't the kid need to be involved?
The dirty tricks those without...
Wait.
The dirty...
The dirty tricks those without the powers of the dead...
Oh.
Oh!
The dirty tricks those without the powers of the dead come up with.
My goodness.
I cannot comprehend this sentence.
Deposit in Mint Bank TM.
Thank you.
Cha-ching!
Deposited.
However...
If I take that precious thing back...
Marisa.
Oh my god.
Cecil stole the precious thing.
I hate you.
Navin.
Ang!
If I take that precious thing back, their power vanishes, doesn't it?
So true.
Look at this.
Look at this bozo sleeping on the job.
Now then.
Time to see how the justice minister's little girl is doing.
Before this guy wakes up from his dream of beauty.
Oh, he's snoring.
I'm going ghost.
Swing.
Decoration.
What's this down here?
Let's open the door.
I think that'll get us furthest.
Oh.
Open the door again.
Wait.
I pressed X.
Oh.
Okay.
I can't go.
I can't ghost trick.
Okay.
Never mind.
What are you doing?
So...
Swing!
Oh.
Doesn't do so much.
Mmhm.
Okay.
Swing!
Why does it go so far to the left?
Not to the right?
Okay.
There's one other thing we can do, which is this.
Burned dry.
Oh.
It's on fire.
Oh, my God.
Oh, we just caused a fire.
Wait.
Oh.
But that's gonna drop then.
I knew it!
Awww.
Oh.
The fire.
Here I thought we were going to be setting the place on fire, but now we swing here.
Arson!
Let's spin faster.
Spin, spin, spin, spin, spin, spin.
Oh, interesting.
Oh, my bad.
Hold on.
Let's see, what did that say?
The ball.
A ball that rolls off a table.
I've already seen something like this once already tonight.
It's true.
I wonder if this ball does anything.
Okay.
Now we're here, here...
Lower the shade...
Move the sconce...
Suspend the shelf... I meant the clock.
Let's move down.
Lower the shade.
I'm under his... Oh, darn.
I can't reach my destination from here.
Okay.
Thank you.
What if we rock and the clock falls?
No.
The shelf is suspended by very thin cords.
They look like they're about to break.
I bet it'd be quite a spectacle if that...
If something can break it...
Oh, wait.
If something can break, it kind of makes me want to break it.
Oh, my gosh.
Cecil.
Why are you such a...
Why are you such a troublemaker, huh?
What?
That's just... Huh?
This is one of those things you light with fire, isn't it?
Do we need to really set this place on fire?
As long as there's light in the room.
Is something like this really necessary?
But if something can be lit, it kind of makes me want to light it.
I need another core to reach the trunk and open it.
I wonder if I can create a new core.
So we need to... We need to burn this.
We need to set things on fire, baby.
He is truly a menace.
Doll.
Let's go back to where we were before.
Oh, I'm already feeling myself getting so hungry.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Yeah, we can...
Oh,
wait.
We can... We can go back this way.
Like so.
Okay.
Easy peasy.
Hmm.
Now, if I open the door...
Oh!
I was gonna possess the ball.
Hmm.
Food check.
I have my food.
It's just hard to eat when I'm reading so much, you know?
Sorry, guys.
Before...
Before stream, I was recording with...
With Matara for the podcast.
And, um...
We started kind of late because we both got back from doctor's appointments late.
Hahaha.
Hmm.
Okay.
Can I set anything else on fire?
What else can I set on fire?
Hmm.
Oh!
Nice!
We can... We can...
Fire!
Hahaha.
Burn, baby.
Burn.
My heart.
Hmm?
Heartburn?
If you have heartburn, are you okay?
I don't wanna do this out of order and have to restart.
So, let's see.
The present?
Hmm.
Set our hearts ablaze?
You want me to set you on fire?
Joshua, thank you!
Good evening, man.
A few more dollars for the mental bank.
Have you heard...
Hearing you sing Final Fantasy songs warms my JRPG-loving heart.
Do you have a favorite Final Fantasy game?
I'll be honest, I haven't played so many Final Fantasy games.
Um...
So, I probably like my first one, which was...
Um, Final...
Well, actually, I played Final Fantasy X-2 first.
But, uh...
I really like Final Fantasy X and X-2.
Hmm.
Let's see what happens if we spin this.
It's gonna go up...
And then it goes back down.
Okay.
But I can't do anything while it's doing that.
Cool.
Um...
Maybe...
Maybe we have this firecracker.
Okay, you know what?
Let's just go party popper.
Fire!
Oh!
I was gonna say...
Maybe if...
Ah!
I was gonna say...
Maybe...
Um...
Would...
Get something stuck either on the spinner or on the fan.
Nice.
Okay.
6, 9 and 12 are my favorites.
Oh, and then I've also...
I've played a little bit of 7.
But I know...
I've watched playthroughs of 7, so...
Just my imagination.
That's all he has to say.
If he was any more laid back, he'd fall right off that crate.
But look at that streamer going...
Go...
Go spinning round and round.
Now, how can I make use of that?
Yes.
Where am I?
Oh, I'm on the party popper.
Maybe we get it tied up here.
Get tied up!
How far does it reach?
Not enough for the firecracker.
I think I'm just gonna have to set the place on fire.
Fire!
Oh!
That leads...
Just my imagination.
That leads straight up to the fire.
Fire, fire, light the fire.
What an amazingly simple fellow.
This room, on the other hand, is starting to look amazingly festive.
The question is, how can I use it to my advantage?
Okay.
If I...
Go up here...
If I bring this up now, what does it do?
Oh!
It's all tied up.
Interesting.
Okay.
I'm still confused what to do with the spinning guy, though.
Hmm.
I'm actually kind of stumped.
Whatever.
Yeah.
There's the...
There's a candle on the doll, too.
Yes.
I have noticed that.
I have noted that.
Yes.
I think...
Does the...
Does the string...
Hold on.
Let's see.
Does it reach...
No, it doesn't...
I was like, maybe if that catches on fire and then spins over to her...
Hmm.
We've done.
Let's raise it...
The fire again, maybe.
Hmm.
Here we go.
Ghost!
And back this way.
Aw dang.
And this way.
And this way, this way, this way, this way.
Burn brighter.
Not...
It doesn't reach.
When the flame gets really big like this for some reason, I get the urge to burn something.
Unfortunately, everything is just out of the flame.
There's nothing else I can interact with except the door.
Oh, come on.
Oh, come on!
Oh, maybe spin faster.
That's right.
Okay, that's right.
Okay, there we go, there we go.
Burn, burn, burn, burn, burn!
Burn, burn, burn, burn, burn, burn!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, it's on fire.
Oh, I figured it out.
Good luck.
I figured it out too!
Wait.
Okay, so that's on fire now.
And now we need to raise this...
to be on fire as well.
I figured it out too.
Spin!
What about the ball though?
Nice!
Oh!
Just your imagination.
Tensai.
Thank you, thank you.
And we're in, baby.
That's the daughter?
Wait, she's just chilling.
What in the...
What's going on here?
Whose footprints are these?
This little lady is...
Her.
I thought it was the girl in the bed.
Is this little lady really a daughter of the justice minister?
Oh, just my imagination.
It was not...
Oh!
Uh...
They caught the wrong girl.
What's with the fun book and juice?
Like I said.
Always keep a smile on a lady's face.
I wanted to treat our guest well.
How about treating me well?
Ooh!
Oh my gosh, Shaggy.
Are you telling you're not treating my girl well?
Should have been me.
I'll treat you well.
I'll treat you well, Madame Blue.
Mm-hmm.
I volunteer.
I'd like some bread and milk, please.
Not your sor...
Oh no, am I Shaggy?
Why did I know what he was going to say?
Oh no.
I don't know.
You're a maid, that's why?
Yes, yes, yes.
That's all.
It's only because I'm a maid, everybody.
Oh no.
Not your service, my dear.
Me back in a flash.
You better skedaddle out of there.
I better see you.
I better see dust coming off your feet from running so fast.
Hey, mister.
I think she also wants bread and milk.
Yes, cute little lady.
More juice, perhaps?
All you have to do is ask.
Have I been kidnapped?
Oh.
Don't cry, little dear.
There's nothing to be afraid of.
The surroundings are miserable and filthy, I know.
But we just ask for a little patience.
Don't say those ugly words.
Don't say those awful things about this house.
This house is...
Where I used to live.
So what does...
What does the guy from the...
How does the guy...
From the...
Junkyard...
Know...
What her room looks like?
Zoinks.
What?
I apologize, little lady.
I'm the one who's miserable and filthy.
Forgive me.
Wait, so...
I think my theory last time was that...
Was that...
Uh...
Lin killed...
Um...
The mom?
But now I'm thinking...
Um...
Maybe...
It was accidentally...
Her.
What's her name?
Now I'm thinking is that maybe it's her...
Instead.
And that's...
But Lin still knows the truth about Detective Jowd.
Camilla.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
DL6 incident?
Ah...
That would be on...
That would be...
That would be on brand for this...
For this creator.
What's the meaning of this beauty?
I don't know.
Why here?
At this...
At this girl's old house?
Don't ask me.
It was the other party in our deal who chose this location.
Oh...
Oh, I see.
It's been empty for five years and apparently nobody ever comes here.
But never mind that.
What about my bread and milk?
Oh...
Oh, of course.
Skedaddle now.
Shaggy.
Now you be a good girl while I'm gone.
Oh my god.
Look at him tiptoe.
Hurry up.
Go get the bread and milk.
Let the ladies speak.
You just read your book and drink your juice.
You'll never know the truth.
There's not a parrot in sight.
I wanna go home.
Not quite yet.
This dilapidated place was Camilla's old house?
What's going on here?
Trick time.
Alright, Camilla.
Camilla...
Wait, what in the world?
Why does the little lady have a core of the dead?
I was gonna say, she never died before.
When I helped her out at Lin's apartment...
Wait, no.
She did die technically though, right?
Because...
Um...
Wait.
Actually, I'm not sure.
No.
Because he killed the dog and then her.
But we never talked to her.
It was her dog.
Oh, you're right.
Maybe I just assumed that she was going to die.
But it was actually her going to get kidnapped.
When I helped her out at Lin's apartment...
She didn't have one.
So that must mean...
She must have died sometime after that.
Once again, the incident.
Wait, what incident?
And it also means...
Somebody else must have saved her.
Wait, what?
I'd better ask her what happened.
Unless...
Unless something that we fixed saved her, right?
That could happen.
What's the book she's reading?
A book?
I wonder what the little lady is reading tonight.
An exciting adventure story, maybe?
Although she's already getting quite a bit of excitement for one day.
Look at her sipping.
She's so cute.
Somewhere along the way, Camilla must have died.
What could have happened to her?
I'd better ask her.
Who could it be?
There's somebody else with the powers of the dead besides me.
I don't know.
Okay.
Let's get inside her brain.
Who's there?
Oh, wait a minute.
Is that you, Missile?
Wait, Missile?
Missile?
I'm sorry.
I'm not Missile.
My name's Sissel.
Did Missile save her?
No way.
Sissel?
My name is Camilla.
Yeah, where is Missile actually?
Camilla.
So, it is her.
I knew it.
What happened to me?
What is this place?
I can hardly tell the poor little thing.
Oh, I can hardly tell the poor little thing.
This is the land of the dead.
The land of the dead?
What does that mean?
Oh, she could hear our thoughts.
Does that mean I'm dead?
Darn.
I forgot there are no secrets in the ghost world.
You can relax.
You're not dead.
But this isn't the first time you've been in the ghost world.
You've been here, apparently.
Really?
I don't remember.
There are no thoughts here.
Wait a minute.
Maybe I do remember.
Sort of.
What?
May
I have a birthday song?
My wish this year is to go to Mint's meet and greet.
Thank you!
Of course I can sing you.
Hold on.
For some reason, it's so loud for me, but it's not so loud for you.
I will sing you happy birthday.
Hold on.
Let me...
Hold on first.
OK.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear.
Happy birthday to you!
Woo!
I'll hope your birthday wish comes true.
Also, I saw someone say that the game is loud?
It is?
How about here?
Maybe I do remember, sort of.
It's fine?
You do?
It looks like she doesn't remember being saved very well.
Was that not good before?
Like there?
So there's some other dead person out there with special powers, eh?
Anyway, I don't want to press her if she doesn't remember dying.
Do you mind if I ask you a few questions about something else?
Sure, go ahead, sissy!
Sissy, eh?
Kidnapping.
Lynn asked me to do something for her tonight.
I know about that part.
She asked you to go to the chicken kitchen on Dead End Drive, right?
Sissy.
Yeah, but I never got there.
Now I wish I could say I'm sorry to her.
I never should have gone through that park.
What park?
Temsik Park.
It's a shortcut to Dead End Drive.
Oh my gosh, did she like get hit by the truck?
Did she get isekai'd?
Is that where the kidnappers grabbed you?
Yeah, Lynn always says.
Always said.
I don't like that park.
Scary things happen there.
That's where she also got held hostage, right?
Yeah, that's where we...
That's where she got held hostage.
HMS, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Temsik Park, eh?
What am I going to do?
Lynn's going to be so mad.
Aww.
She's not going to be mad that you got kidnapped.
Well, she's going to be mad that you got kidnapped.
Yeah, she's going to be mad.
She is?
How come?
Uh-oh.
Because I left it there.
It's probably the music box.
Vanilla, welcome to membership.
The music box in the park.
This is the music box that...
Um...
That, uh...
Detective Jowd said that we needed to look into.
That's right, the music box.
Oh, let's ask her.
That music box was hidden in the apartment.
I finally found it with a little bit of luck and courage.
Mwah.
And me.
Actually, just me.
Guess where it was.
I don't know.
Where?
I'll pretend I don't...
She can still hear our thoughts.
I'll pretend I don't know.
You know.
Hello,
welcome to membership.
You don't have to humor me.
Oops.
So what happened to the music box?
I hid it in the bushes at the park just before it happened.
Just before?
Oh, just before you were kidnapped, huh?
I didn't want the bad man to take it, so I hid it.
I bet it's still there in the park.
You did well.
So the music box is in the park.
I'd better let Lynn know.
All right, let's ask about Camilla.
This is your old house?
Yep.
This is where we lived until five years ago.
But now I live with Lynn and Mistle.
Lynn is like a big sister to you, isn't she?
Yep.
She's a detective, you know.
She's a hero.
She is, huh?
Why are you so surprised by that?
By the way, about your father.
Is he the detective?
Is he the justice minister?
My father is gone.
Gone?
Maybe he passed away?
No, that's not it.
My dad...
Is Detective Jowd.
He's going to die.
And it's all because of me.
What?
What do you mean because of me?
Why would you say that?
Oh my God, was I right?
It's called an execu...
I'm sorry.
Uh-oh.
It's called an execution.
My dad is...
A detective.
No way.
Don't tell me your father is...
Detective Jowd?
That's right.
I so called it.
What in the world?
Five years ago, something really bad happened.
Like a scary dream.
But it wasn't a dream.
Five years ago...
I'm sorry.
That murder case...
Was the guy in the...
She didn't kill her mom either!
Was the guy...
In the...
In the park?
Junkyard?
Was he recreating how...
How...
The mom died?
You know?
Oh...
Maybe...
Or...
Something...
What are you cooking?
Five years ago...
That murder case...
Incident five years ago...
That was my mom's birthday that day.
My mom and dad were working and I was home by myself.
And then I had an idea.
I was going to go to work.
I was going to surprise my mom.
She set up a contraption.
And she thinks she killed her mom.
I set up...
Okay.
What the hell?
I promise.
I have not played this game before.
What is going on?
Literally the next line.
Am I...
I'm so psychic today.
Wow.
Pre-watched.
Are you reading...
Are you reading a synopsis, man?
No!
I promise.
I set up that contraption.
Oh, my God.
I'm home, Camilla.
Why is it dark?
Oh, my God.
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
And then it set on fire and everything died.
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
What was the point of all the rest of it?
Why did you set this up?
What did you think was going to happen?
What was that noise?
Still can't believe that happened.
It wasn't supposed to work like that.
So, someone messed with it.
Someone tampered with her contraption.
I know that contraption!
Yes!
It's exactly what I said!
And I know how it was supposed to work!
Wait, how was it supposed to work?
Wait, I know how it was supposed to work?
It was supposed to... the poppers!
Yeah, it was supposed to do the poppers!
That's right.
Party poppers and a cake and a birthday message.
Yes, yes, now I remember, now I remember.
Camilla lost her mom to a TikTok challenge.
Don't say it like that.
Mint hasn't played the game before.
That means she made it.
I haven't seen the creator of Ghost Trick and Mint in the same room before.
Yes, we redirected the cupid.
That's right.
But also, why was the gun loaded?
My dad told me not to tell anybody.
Just leave it to me, he said.
Aww, poor girl.
My dad wanted to be executed.
He asked them for it.
Okay, name, welcome to membership.
But I wanted to tell everybody it was my fault!
My dad said what I saw was a bad dream.
He told me to forget it.
This is all so unbelievably tragic.
America, who doesn't have a loaded gun on their wall?
So true.
I can't believe it.
This little lady is Detective Jowd's daughter.
Girl, your contraption is absolutely killing it.
I can't tell her.
I just can't tell her.
I can't tell her why she was kidnapped.
ZK!
Thanks for the 10 gift and thank you!
Why was I kidnapped?
I want to know!
Oops.
There are no secrets in the ghost world.
Maybe we'd better stop talking.
It's too dangerous.
Sissy, you're not going to talk to me anymore?
I think we'd better get you out of here first.
We can talk more after that.
Okay, but...
Oops.
I love how he just goes, oops.
Whoopsie-poopsie.
I'm going to rescue you now.
You just hold on a little longer, alright?
Okay, but we'll talk later, right?
Don't forget.
You promised, Sissy.
Yippie.
Different places have different traditions.
Birthday punches, birthday death contraptions, they're all equally valid.
Only the strong survive the birthday contraption.
What took you so long?
Wait, sorry.
I traveled the entire town in search of the finest bread and milk for you, my dear.
But it's late, and all the shops are closed.
We're leaving this place right now.
I don't... I can't get her voice right anymore.
What?
But he's not here yet.
If we couldn't meet at the restaurant, weren't we supposed to meet here?
Yes, and he's the one who chose this location.
I don't like this one bit.
I can never un-hear Shaggy.
I think I'm leaning more into the Shaggy since I can't stop it.
It's just happening.
Let it... let Shaggy take over, okay?
Let... let...
Kinda sounds like Shaggy from Skipper.
Just let this Shaggy take over, okay?
We have to run around doing all this extra work all for the sake of his deal.
Be quiet.
It can't be helped.
This place is too dangerous.
I told you, my sixth sense is very strong.
Oh, she senses me.
As you wish, beauty.
I feel it.
I sense something.
Here.
In this room.
It's me.
Is somebody there?
Can you hear me?
She's talking to me.
She's talking to me, you guys.
Straight to me.
I can sense your presence, you know.
The next time I sense you, this child will...
This child will die.
Remember that.
Oh my god.
Okay.
I'm just obsessed with you.
All right.
We're leaving.
Pardon me, little lady.
Oh, recently I discovered VTubers and I love your streams.
Really?
Thank you so much.
Thanks, dude.
Thanks for the super chat.
Like soinks mint.
We gotta get out of here.
Raggy.
All of a sudden, I'm left behind alone.
Alone in the room that stole that little lady's smile away five years ago.
The little lady is gone now.
Leaving me with only a few new facts.
A few very heavy, very sad facts.
Does Lynn know about all this?
Raggy.
One other thing stands out in my mind.
I can sense your presence.
The sum of that kidnapper's final words.
Do those two know?
Do the kidnappers know about the powers of the dead?
Would you spare the girl for a Scooby Snack?
Ba-da-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Yay!
Cleared the 1225 challenge.
It's crazy that all of this happens in just like 15 minutes.
Oh my gosh, Camilla is so cute.
Continue playing?
Of course.
I don't know what chapter we're on now.
Oh.
Chapter 12.
Yeah.
40 minutes late.
Now I feel so lost.
I can catch you up.
Um.
Uh.
Here.
Read this.
Hold on.
Uh.
I'm gonna eat.
You read it.
Someone read it out loud.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba.
Welcome to Why You're Stuck Here.
All your earthly possessions now belong to retowards.
You've missed your chance to run.
Blah.
Thanks for your super time.
I'm glad.
Am I glad she's trapped in there?
Now we're trapped in there.
And that she's the daughter.
And that we're trapped in there.
And now we're in there.
And I just remembered we're out here.
What I want to know is where's Ms. Camilla?
Thank you.
What do you call a ghost dad?
A transparent.
It's transparent.
Get it?
It's a ghost.
Looks like the kidnappers made a big mistake.
The girl in the trunk...
Oh, thank you.
You literally sent a super chat?
You sent a super chat of...
Of what's on the screen.
Okay, I'll read it.
It looks like the kidnappers made a big mistake.
You said to read it out loud.
Okay, sorry.
Hold on.
Let me take a sippy.
Okay.
It looks like the kidnappers made a big mistake.
The girl in the trunk was Detective Zhao's daughter Camilla.
Not the minister's daughter.
Oh, what is going on here?
What are you guys doing?
When I got back to the justice minister's office, things were getting even more out of hand.
The devastated man was being grilled by the fiery detective lady.
Thanks for the money.
Oh, that's what she's doing.
She's going off on him.
I told Lin what I found out about the kidnapping.
That it wasn't the justice minister's daughter who had been abducted.
That the kidnappers had been holed up in Camilla's old house.
And that they sensed my presence and were already gone.
This is a good recap of what just happened.
I hope this caught you up.
But Camilla, why do they have Camilla?
Her father isn't the stupid old justice minister.
I think the stupid old part is a little uncalled for.
Looks like the kidnappers made a mistake somehow.
The poor girl kidnapped for the ransom of her own father's execution.
That is actually...
I did not think about that.
That's actually really messed up.
That's actually so messed up.
I missed the last stream.
How long did it take Min to get past the minister's puzzle?
I don't remember.
I think about each chapter has taken me like an hour or so.
Or a little longer.
I also talk.
But this is really messed up.
It's just too much.
It's a cruel twist of fate.
I agree.
That just ain't right.
And then there are those other twists too.
Like the kidnappers winding up in and using Camilla's old house as their hideout.
There's no way it could be just a coincidence.
And them sensing my presence.
They seem to know about the powers of the dead.
I just don't understand any of it.
Think you're generally decently quick?
Yay!
Thank you.
I told you before, detective.
I want you to stand back.
Bam!
Minus one HP.
Who cares about distance at a time like this?
Look, Mr. Minister.
It wasn't your daughter that was kidnapped.
Don't try to pretend you didn't hear what we were saying.
How can I believe in you?
I'm a realist.
Please!
Minus one HP.
If you don't believe what we said, see for yourself.
Just call home and...
I tried calling a hundred times.
My wife won't answer.
She won't?
It's complicated.
Why does life have to be such a complicated thing?
I don't remember the voice I gave him before.
And I feel like I remember Lin being British.
But I think that was just a Mandela effect.
But if she doesn't answer, doesn't that mean everything's normal?
It doesn't prove it.
And everyone knows ghosts aren't real.
Why would you say that?
Excuse you.
And I'm being watched.
I can't have the police go check for me.
Besides, if the execution isn't carried out tonight, the hostage will be killed.
What difference does it make that it's not my daughter?
I guess that's kind of true.
That's quite a pickle, Mr. Minister.
Quite a pickle.
Oh, my God.
Here comes... the Elvis guy.
I forgot his name.
Miss me, baby?
Oh, Inspector Cavandela!
I thought it was a pasta.
It was carbonara, but it didn't seem right.
He's so cool.
I have a little rapport for you, Mr. Minister.
Oh my goodness!
If you guys don't bow that deep when you greet me...
The escaped prisoner has been apprehended.
Thought you might like to see him, so here he is.
Wait, he's here?
Oh!
Come on in!
Oh my god!
He's just here!
Detective Jowd?
Detective Jowd, I'm so sorry.
I tried.
I'm a nerd.
You think I can bend like that?
Start!
Start stretching!
Wilson Channel, welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
I know that you're innocent.
I just can't prove it.
I'm so sorry.
Lin, please, don't apologize to me.
The reason I don't give him a voice is I think he's just too cool for... I can't do it justice.
You know?
Ah, the beautiful love between a teacher and student.
It brings a tear to my eye.
Trick time!
Oh, what are they saying?
You knew, didn't you, Inspector Carbonara?
That the execution was tonight.
It's the Giga Chen.
Give him snake voice?
I was planning to dogeza for the meet and greet, but alas.
Ah, man.
It's okay.
I'm the maid.
I have to be bowing to you.
You guys don't bow to me.
I bow to you guys.
You're just wisps.
You're all goshijinsama and ojo-sama wisps.
Sorry, I was drooling.
I don't believe I had any obligation to tell you.
What a jerk.
And you're fine with this?
I mean, you know as well as I do.
Detective Child could never have done such a thing.
No, come on, baby.
I know no such thing.
Huh?
I know two things.
Every time I elongate his words, I want to say it like a sheep.
I know two things to be true and two things only.
One, he was given the death penalty.
And two, he tried to escape.
What else could I do but haul him in, baby?
But he's an innocent man!
If that's the case, why did you bring him here?
Whatever do you mean, young lady?
He escaped from prison, right?
So why didn't you just take him back to the prison?
I think you only brought him here...
...to brag about your accomplishment.
Isn't that right, Inspector?
Elvis sheep.
With all these cool character voices, have you ever considered being a dungeon master?
I don't... I've never ever once had the thought.
For your own selfish reasons?
Oh yes, call him out!
Call him out!
This guy's a jerk.
So were all those rumors about you true?
That the only thing you care about is a spotless record?
Is that more important to you than saving a friend?
Shots.
Everybody has certain principles they can't go back on.
Including me.
You'll understand that someday, baby.
I don't like him.
That's enough, Lin.
Oh.
Talked like a snake, right?
But Detective Jowd!
I'm a death...
It doesn't fit him!
I'm a death row inmate who escaped from prison.
It doesn't fit him at all!
This is how it should be.
But... but...
The instant phone.
Oh,
a ghost!
No, I don't want to talk to you.
Oh my god, we can talk to everybody here.
It's kinda crazy.
You know what, we'll start with this guy.
My poor Amelie.
Is she alright?
Actually, the girl who was kidnapped is named...
Camilla.
Why is a dream talking to me in my head again?
Wait a minute.
Amelie?
Wait.
They all can communicate?
They can all go into the death area together?
Interesting.
Could that be the Amelie next door?
Yes, I think so.
Wow, I didn't know the justice minister lived next door.
No, not me.
My wife.
It's... complicated.
Yeah, I bet it was.
That would be pretty hard to admit she...
Wait, there's no secrets in the ghost world, Sissel?
Ghost Skype.
Sissel.
He never learns.
Actually, you know what?
Let everybody know.
The minister's wife ran away on him?
Why was she so happy about that?
Yo, is this Professor Layton versus Ace Attorney?
Yes.
Maybe they grew apart.
What, with him being so busy?
Yeah, I bet you're right.
Please stop gossiping about me inside my own head!
According to what I heard...
Amelie was supposed to go to some sort of lesson tonight.
Those horrible kidnappers!
They were lying in wait for her!
But Amelie didn't go out after all.
She couldn't.
She had a fever.
Huh.
And so the kidnappers grabbed Camilla by mistake instead?
Apparently.
Amelie and Camilla are about the same age.
Hmm.
The kidnappers must have gotten the two of them mixed up.
It's my fault.
If I hadn't asked Camilla to do that errand for me...
This never would have happened.
Oh, right.
You asked her to bring the music box.
Camilla...
Aww.
It's not your fault!
It's not your fault.
Alright, let's go talk to Jowd.
So, Mr. Ghost, we meet again?
I hear something happened.
Something about a kidnapping.
It's your daughter!
Some kidnappers are saying they abducted the Justice Minister's daughter.
That's terrible.
What's their demand?
The carrying out of your execution.
Tonight.
Hahaha!
I had no idea I was so hated.
But the Minister doesn't have to worry.
I die and it's all over.
Very simple.
No, what about your daughter?
It's not that simple!
Why not?
Because it isn't really the Minister's daughter who got kidnapped.
It's Camilla!
You just spat food all over my...
If you could choose to someone's life with...
Wait.
Choose to what?
With ghost trick.
But in exchange, they could hear what you think when you talk to them.
What would you do, ghost man?
What?
Like save someone's life with the ghost trick?
Yeah,
save.
But like what if the death is like really interesting?
Really creative.
Kind of like the death contraption.
Can we hear your thoughts?
What would you want to hear, huh?
What would you...
What do you think that I think in my head that I don't say out loud 99% of the time?
What do you think that I'm thinking about?
Snake.
Lewd thoughts.
My...
Exactly my point.
What do you think that I'm thinking about that I do not say 90...
You know what?
I'll even...
I might drop it a little.
95% of the time.
I have nothing to lose, man, with young daughter.
I know, right?
Nerd stuff.
You know deep down that you're actually cute.
I wish...
I wish I could agree with you there.
Anyway.
Camilla.
I checked it out for myself.
I'm positive.
No, it can't be.
And by the way, Camilla told me something interesting.
She said the one who killed her mother five years ago was Camilla herself.
Oh.
What?
What are you talking about?
Don't listen to him.
I'm the one who shot her.
I'm the one who shot Alma.
And when I'm executed tonight, that will be the end of it.
Camilla won't have to suffer anymore after tonight.
She's suffering because she was a baby.
What do you think she's going to get the death penalty?
This guy is so backwards.
For a capable detective, you say some incredibly misguided things.
Yeah, her dad is going to die.
That means her dad and her mom are going to be dead.
How is that going to end her suffering?
This guy is so stupid.
You dying isn't going to end that girl's suffering.
It'll just bring her new suffering.
The only person's pain this execution is going to ease is yours.
Do you think the lamp was the mom?
The lamp at the very beginning?
But also, facts, Sissel, facts.
Do you think the lamp... do you think the mom is what protected...
Is what protected Camilla from dying before?
That's what I was thinking.
Great minds, great minds.
But I'm just cooking.
No confirming or denying.
We're cooking together, everybody.
Is this true?
What Camilla said?
Why don't you tell us what you know?
The murder five years ago.
To be honest, I still don't understand what happened that day.
It was my wife's... almost birthday.
The lamp is me.
I'm the game.
I believe you, Beancake.
Quake.
Sorry, Beanquake.
We came home from work.
And she went in first.
Oh yeah, that's true.
She did die a long time ago.
And he said that... or the lamp said...
That...
You only get...
But what if that's not actually the case?
What if that's not actually the case?
What if the lamp lied?
What if the lamp lied so that...
So... so that...
We would solve the case tonight.
So that we would have a motive.
Because the lamp seemed to know a lot.
But if they were only around for a little bit of time...
They wouldn't know so much.
What if the lamp is the mom trying to save the dad?
Because she knows that it wasn't him.
Why would a lamp lie?
I looked for the shooter, but there was nobody to be found.
There was nobody there besides Alma and Camilla.
Just the two of them.
So the little lady's mother died right in front of her.
I'm so sad.
That's so horrible.
Camilla told me about it.
She was crying.
The lamp has grandpa voice though.
You're so right.
What was I thinking?
The lamp's a grandpa.
Grandpa?
I have a big question though.
Who is Sissel?
I know.
We still don't know.
But we have to get to the music box.
And then we'll figure it all out.
She said the contraption she made did something it wasn't supposed to.
Made an impossible move.
An impossible move.
I love...
You know what?
Maybe Sissel needs the snake voice.
Since he talks like snake.
The powers of the dead.
It's been five years since then.
I stopped thinking about it.
I shot Alma.
There's no other explanation.
That's what I'd convince everyone of.
Even me.
But tonight, you showed up and gave me an explanation I never would have thought of before.
The powers of the dead, right?
That day in that room, powers that I didn't understand were at work.
And if that's the case, it clears up...
All the mysteries.
So a ghost?
That doesn't save lives, but kills lives!
Oh my god!
An evil ghost!
Maybe not all.
There are a couple of other people who know about those powers.
Is somebody there?
Can you hear me?
I can sense your presence, you know.
The kidnappers...
The kidnappers knew...
Wait, the kidnappers who abducted Camilla knew about those powers.
This is no ordinary kidnapping.
It looks like my wife's case isn't coming to an end after all.
I'm the only one who thought it was.
Yeah!
Liquid Sissel!
Detective Jowd.
There's still time before dawn.
A little, anyway.
How about you see this case through to the end before you die?
I only know one other ghost.
Mint.
What have you been up to on the side?
A little...
Kind of like, you know, a little...
This and that.
Right and left, up and down.
Hmm...
That sock that went missing last week?
On the dark web.
Being sold.
You know, that cake you were saving?
That disappeared all of a sudden?
Yeah, you ate it.
But I possessed you when you did.
Officer, there's a ghost right here.
No, no, no!
I'm innocent.
No, no, no, no!
I'm innocent, I promise.
I didn't do a thing!
I didn't...
This wasn't me.
It wasn't me.
An impossible move.
Camilla was a quiet little girl.
But she was good with her hands.
She was a little genius.
Hahaha.
She's a little genius!
No!
Don't put me next to the police!
Of course it wasn't!
It was supposed to be a surprise for her mother's birthday!
And the other strange point was the movement of that cupid.
Yeah,
the paupers were supposed to go...
It was supposed to shoot its arrow without turning around.
Why did it turn around?
Just like that!
Maybe!
Maybe we avoid having contraptions with using fire, you know?
And that girl's name?
Albert Einstein.
Somebody made a change to the contraptions design and then manipulated it.
I don't know what to say!
I didn't have time to think things through then.
All I knew was I had to protect Camilla.
I made a small adjustment to the scene and turned myself in.
Adjustment to the scene?
What kind of an adjustment?
The gun, of course.
The gun, eh?
Come to think of it.
Oh yeah, I was missing!
There was no gun there.
Just a picture hanging on the wall.
Of course not.
Because I secretly switched the gun out of that frame with the picture.
I didn't believe what she told me about her contraption.
Why did you believe her?
But one thing was for certain.
That gun was still smoking.
So that gun really did shoot Alma.
I hid the gun before I went to the police.
You hid it?
I put it in a wooden box and gave it to a certain detective.
Me?
Or her?
Wait, is it in the music box?
You mean...
She still thinks it's a music box!
So that's...
Oh my gosh, you just gave her a gun?
Dang.
So that's what was in the box, huh?
I got a different murder weapon ready to give to the police.
My own pistol.
And I did a few other... but...
No, that doesn't make any sense.
If you give your own pistol to the police, the bullets wouldn't match up.
You said it was an antique gun.
That's the evidence that you need!
The bullets wouldn't match up!
Keep reading.
Read his line.
Oh, and I did a few other things to make it look good.
I won't go into the details.
When I was all done, I turned myself in.
Oh, he said that it matched.
Oh, he did?
Wait.
Huh?
Maybe he shot the corpse?
Oh, he did a few other things.
Huh?
That's... what?
That's... that's...
How could you?
Like, even if someone...
Even if someone were dead...
If they were like my husband or wife, I wouldn't be able to reshoot them at all.
What?
Oh my god.
So anyway, I started blasting.
When I was all done, I turned myself in.
Wowee.
That...
That's...
That's a lot.
Damn, I thought I was onto something too.
I was just like...
Damn it, Detective Jowd.
Why did you have to be so thorough?
I was like, just go find the bullet.
It'll be fine.
Damn it.
Detective Jowd, is what you told us just now true?
Hmm.
Yes, of course.
In that case, there's still time.
Still time?
Time to solve the case that started five years ago.
You didn't do it, Detective Jowd.
And of course, little Camilla didn't do it either.
So the true perpetrator is still out there.
And I'm going to prove it.
For Camilla's sake.
That sounds wonderful.
Yeah!
He's on our side now.
Thank you, Detective Jowd.
Lin, where is that music box now?
In Temsik Park.
Camilla left it there.
Wait.
Don't just yell this out to everybody.
We don't know who we can trust.
That gun is important evidence.
You'd better go pick it up.
Don't just tell everybody.
Yes, sir.
I'll go right now.
Cecil, take care of Detective Jowd.
And do something about the kidnapping so we can get the minister on our side.
And yet again I say, easy enough for you to say.
Uh.
Is he...
Is anybody...
Are they not going to be like, oh, what the...
What was that?
What's going on?
Deal me the deal, Mr. Deathrow and mate.
Hmm.
A little change in plans.
My daughter has been kidnapped.
I can't just go off to die without doing something.
But you're in our custody.
Don't forget it.
Back at the prison, everybody's waiting for you with a special seat just for you, bebe.
Then I guess we'd better prove my innocence.
Oh, you're trying to prove my innocence on the double?
On the double, is it?
You sound so determined, my old friend.
Hmm.
I want to save Camilla in more ways than one.
Yeah!
And that's all there is to it.
Didn't the chair blow up?
It did.
The chair did blow up.
So what are they going to do now?
Oh my God.
They're going to put poison in the chicken.
I see, my old friend.
In more ways than one.
You're going to get it.
What say you, Mr. Minister?
May we have your decision?
Please, please, Mr. Minister.
Should the execution be carried out tonight as planned?
Or should we hold off and wait for this important evidence to come in?
It's not your daughter!
The order still stands.
This guy sucks!
We should have never saved him.
Poison chicken.
Bring the prisoner back immediately and resume its enforcement.
No!
As you wish, Your Excellency.
Oh, my God.
Please don't bow down to me.
And especially not that low!
In that case, can I have one of your... booze?
Boy!
Arrange for a prison van to pick him up.
Oh, my goodness.
I always have boo on the mind.
Would you be so kind?
Yes, sir!
Where
did that come from?
Are you just going to stare at me?
What are you, obsessed with me?
The van should take about ten minutes, I'm guessing.
Your escape tonight was brilliant.
Will you show me another miracle in these last few minutes of yours, Mr. Death Row inmate?
Thank you, Amelia!
Thanks for a month!
VTuber.
Thank you!
Let's see.
We got to show a miracle, huh?
Glad to see Detective Jowd all fired up now.
I feel like I'm under the gun here.
Even if Lin does come through with the proof of Jowd's innocence, it will be meaningless if Jowd or Camilla dies.
I've got to do something about that kidnapping somehow.
Maybe I should ask for some advice from the capable detective here.
Or... we spear him.
Or we spear him.
Let's go get inside this guy's head.
Um, excuse me, Mr. Minister?
I'm going to haunt you until the day you die.
I can't hear you.
La la la la.
I'm sure you've heard everything we've been saying.
Are you telling me you don't believe any of it?
Let me speak plainly.
I don't trust you.
But there's somebody else whom I trust even less.
Oh yeah?
Who's that?
Me!
I can't explain your existence.
It's not normal.
But I'm pretty abnormal myself.
So maybe you're a figment of my imagination.
A delusion.
Oh my god.
The voices.
Would you listen to a delusion?
To be honest, I have no idea what you're talking about.
I got the bit about you not trusting me, though.
Good.
Most likely, the minister won't stop the execution.
The voices.
The lulu is the salulu.
Not as long as there's any small chance his daughter is the one who was kidnapped.
But she isn't the one.
I'm sure of it.
Well, it would be great if we could prove that to the minister.
Prove it how?
We have to get them to call.
We have to get the wife to call him.
I doubt his wife is ever going to answer that phone if we call from here.
If we call from here, right?
But a telephone works in both directions.
Yes, yes, yes.
What are you saying?
What I'm saying is only family members can solve a family problem.
Hey, Mr. Ghost?
Yes?
I have to admit, I don't like depending on others.
But you're the only one who can change the situation.
Gee, detective.
For these past five years, Camilla is the only thing that kept me going.
I can't go meekly to the chair now.
I hate to ask this.
But would you mind saving me?
I'll try.
The key to getting the justice minister to stop the execution is his wife and daughter.
But is there a way?
Oh my gosh, we're going back to the lady.
Wait, can I...
No, it won't let me go anywhere else.
Okay.
Time to...
Can I knock this off?
This brave little water pitcher just saved the justice minister's life.
He drank all of the water, so now it's empty.
I think he should get it refilled.
You never know when another fit may visit.
So true.
Hanging around here won't change anything.
I've got ten minutes before the prison van shows up.
If I could just do something about the kidnapping in those ten minutes...
I guess the telephone lines are my only hope.
Okay.
Let's make it the best ten minutes of our lives, baby.
Uh, lady's red apartment.
Stay hydrated, everyone.
Just as I thought.
This little girl is safe in her bed.
Okay.
She's so cute.
She reminds me of...
Did I say this last time?
She reminds me of Beatrice from ReZero.
Murder.
Execution.
Jailbreak.
Betrayal.
And now kidnapping.
This last link in this long chain of a sad fate lit a fire in Jao's heart.
I did?
And the chance to turn it all around is right here in this room.
You guys...
If you ever think...
If you ever think I'm not sincere...
I always think the same things.
I always think the same things over and over again.
I guess that was all we did.
Now enjoy some of your life.
Thank you.
See you in another chapter.
I'm getting a strange premonition.
Everything that happened so far tonight has related back to me in some way.
And I bet this mistaken ridden abduction does too.
I'm so curious who Cecil is!
Oh that was the end of the chapter.
Oh interesting.
We just cleared all the chapter.
I've got this illustration now.
Even though Cabanela is tall and lovely.
Well, one of those words describes him as definitely not tall.
Continue playing.
It's only been an hour and a half.
That was a shorter chapter, wasn't it?
I visited the novelist's apartment again.
I'm hoping to be able to do something about this mistaken identity kidnapping.
As long as there's any possibility that it could be his own daughter who was kidnapped, I doubt the justice minister will call off the execution tonight.
I'm studying, so keep me company, Minto.
I'll be here!
The key to dispelling the minister's doubts is now in bed, coughing.
And I need to use this key...
And I need to use this key before that prison van arrives to pick up our death row inmate.
Oh my god.
There she's back.
She's back, baby!
This poor girl.
She's so sick.
My darling angel.
Oh, just listen to that cough.
You naughty thing.
Did you leave your nice warm bed here?
I wanted to go out into the night to play.
A daughter after my own heart.
But I must confess, I didn't even notice you were gone.
Ding!
That's... that's not anything to brag about.
I didn't go out to play.
I went to buy Papa a birthday present.
He said he wanted a new lighter.
Okay.
But that's no reason to go out this late at night.
But my fever finally went down.
I could barely move before that.
But look what it brought you.
Your fever is worse now than ever.
Here is to the feverish passion of my darling angel.
Ding!
31st, bam!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Mama.
Yes, darling?
Let's call Papa and wish him a happy birthday.
Even though it's already past midnight.
Mama.
Hmm...
Not tonight, Amelie.
Okay.
I hate you!
Mint coughing baby.
Shut up!
Shut up, nanoplasm!
I had the lady's voice stuck in my head all day after the last time you did it?
OMG.
It looks like this little girl was safe all along.
I already knew that.
But I'm still relieved.
All the same.
What did I do?
You!
Don't turn my coughs into baby coughs.
Don't turn my coughs into baby cough...
baby cough...
listening...
listening files.
You!
There's another...
another lucky development too.
Amelie wants to call her father.
Now if I can make use of that...
that feeling somehow...
that would surely bring the justice minister around.
Wait, so that's a lighter right there?
Do we have to just...
light the shelf on fire and have it move the phone closer to her?
Trick time!
Light it!
Oh, easy!
More arson!
The phone!
Don't look at...
Oh, don't look!
No, no, no, no, no!
Hurry up!
Call!
Amelie, I told you you couldn't call him tonight.
Why not?
Listen to me, Amelie.
Your father is about to make a big mistake.
I want him to reconsider.
What do you know about it, Mama?
He's the one who's the justice minister, you know.
All you do is write weird novels.
I'm almost tired of it.
What?
What are you doing?
Are you my sister?
Who are you?
Are you my big sister?
Yes!
And are you my boyfriend?
No, don't call!
How dare you expect me to forgive such an insult!
It's called hentai and it's an art.
No!
I knew it wouldn't be so easy.
She's working on milk farm too.
Let her cook then!
I can hear you, you know.
What a pair.
I don't know what this family's issues are.
But I do know I have to do something about this lady so Amelie can call.
Fire!
Set it on fire!
Okay, we have the wastebasket.
Let's see.
Oh!
Are we gonna start an electrical fire?
Let's start an electrical fire.
Awesome!
Okay.
Let's see.
What happens if I do this?
Too... too what?
Swing hard!
Too weak!
Look at him go!
Well, I don't know what it's supposed to do though.
Poor little guy.
What does she say here?
She coughs?
Mama, what is Papa about to do?
Never mind.
Nothing you need to know right now, Amelie.
Why is everything always such a big secret?
I'm part of this family too, you know.
It's not something for children's ears.
You'll understand someday.
I don't want to know someday.
I want to know now.
It's not fair.
You just don't want to tell me.
I just want to wish Papa a happy birthday.
Not tonight.
If it was up to me, I'd let her call him.
Thanks, Cecil.
How nice.
If he swings harder...
I don't know.
Let's see.
Let's go back up here.
Turn this.
Hoist.
Turn that.
Examine the dictionary.
The lady's dictionary.
Wasn't this on her desk before?
The poor thing.
Destined to never be returned to the bookshelves.
Hoist.
Return this valve.
Oh, make it chime.
Bing bong.
Well, well.
Having a good time, are we, little rodent?
Yes, mommy.
Sweet dreams.
This poor guy...
Wait.
Did you fancy the vintage, my whiskered friend?
Ding.
But it moved over the lamp.
Or not the lamp.
The um...
The chandelier.
The sconce.
She's more powerful than I thought.
It looks like she tipped the wall...
Oh.
Candelabra.
A candelabra to one side too.
Hmm.
The angle of those candles.
I get the feeling I've seen something very similar to that quite recently.
Yes, we have.
I
better not put out the lamp right now.
It will only pour oil on the flames of anger in this lady's heart.
If I want to give Amelie a chance to use the telephone, I have to think of a way to keep her mother out of the way.
So we turn the rat to the other side.
And we get her to turn around.
Turn, turn, turn.
There we go.
Oh!
Oh my god, this poor rat!
No, this poor rat!
Oh.
Uh-oh.
Oh, heaven's a blackout at a critical time like this.
Of course, dim lights suit my story of love very well, but I myself am not very fond of the dark.
Is the rat okay?
Oh!
This chandelier just narrowly missed the back of my head.
I love the thrill of romance, but I don't need these kinds of thrills.
Thank you.
I forgot that she lights it with her ass.
Wow!
She's gonna drink that?
Ah, what a wonderful atmosphere.
Perfect for a clandestine meeting in the dusky twilight.
Trick time.
Okay.
I don't exactly know how this situation came about, but I think I owe that rat an apology.
The rat seems to be unconscious.
But now that the room has changed into this, maybe I can use it somehow.
Yes.
So the rat...
If I crank this...
Oh!
My goodness, that scared me.
What a naughty chandelier.
Sorry, ma'am.
So...
Sorry, I'm so...
I'm naughty.
I'm a naughty chandelier.
If the rat died, you'd have to go back in time to save it.
You're right.
Can I open this?
It doesn't do anything.
I can't tell if I'm being timed here or not.
You know?
Swing harder?
No.
Hmm...
Burn brighter.
Wow.
We need to get something...
to swing on...
the clock, maybe.
Um...
Or...
If I lower it...
Hmm...
The music is relaxing.
It is kind of making me sleepy.
I'm not gonna lie.
If I turn this again...
It doesn't do anything.
The lights are out.
So it doesn't really matter anyway.
Um...
Nothing there.
Something related to the dictionary?
Let's try it.
Okay.
The lady's dictionary.
Wasn't this on the disc before?
Yup.
Nope.
And I can't reach anything over on the other side.
I don't think they have anything to do with it this time.
Can I get her hair?
When she leans back...
Oh.
Dang.
That was close.
Hmm...
Okay.
Drop it!
Oh!
It's okay.
A little bit more.
That was close too.
I want to see what Cecil says about it.
Ah...
Twice she managed to dodge like that.
Who knew she was such a dodging champion?
I'm starting to get annoyed.
Let me try that again.
I'll get her this time.
Okay.
She's too good.
She is.
And walk, walk, walk.
Down!
Help me!
I'm sorry, mama.
I'm too dizzy.
I can't get up.
I'm afraid I can't help you right now.
Here is to the weakness of my darling angel.
Ding!
That chandelier is on there tighter than her wedding band.
She won't be able to escape on her own.
Okay.
Crank?
Oh my god, this is kind of messed up.
What is going on here?
Emily, look!
Do you see this?
Help me, please!
Sorry, I'm too sick.
I can't get out of bed.
What is going on?
My head is...
What?
No, she doesn't have a southern accent.
My head is spinning.
So I guess I'll just have to stay up there spinning too.
Um...
Looks like this lady won't be going anywhere for a while.
Now the little girl can call her father.
Yeah, but we still have to get her to reach the phone.
The only trouble is she can't reach it.
I guess I'll just have to deliver it to her.
Wait.
That's right.
The angle of those candles.
I saw something very similar just recently, didn't I?
Yeah, yeah.
So if I burn brighter...
Excuse me, ma'am.
Oh my god!
Okay, okay, okay.
And then... wait.
Swing harder?
Swing harder!
Oh, it got the rat.
Oh, there we go.
I had a feeling that it might be the rat.
Now I really owe that poor rat an apology.
This might be a really good chance for me too.
I have to get that phone to Amelie.
Okay.
Swing harder!
Oh my god.
This is chaos.
This is absolute chaos.
Arson!
There we go.
Mama!
What in the world is going on?
I think we're over it now.
Everything is all good.
Oh my goodness.
Why was it so shaky?
Troy enters the room with pizza.
Literally that meme.
Yes.
Oh goody.
Excuse me a minute.
While I call Papa.
Okay, Mama.
I'll only be a minute.
Don't you dare, Amelie.
Get me down.
Sorry, I'm getting...
Hello, Papa.
Amelie.
You know what's kind of messed up about this situation?
Is...
You know...
It's kind of like what he said.
Even if it's not his daughter that's been kidnapped.
There's still a daughter.
Or still someone that...
Still a young girl that has been kidnapped.
That...
The...
The ransom is the death of the guy.
But he's just like...
Well, it's not my daughter.
So...
I guess it doesn't matter if she dies.
Is that you?
Of course it is, silly.
What did you think?
But I heard...
They said you were...
Your mother.
No, never mind.
It's nothing.
Silly old Papa.
Happy birthday, Papa.
Birthday?
Oh, right.
It was my birthday today, wasn't it?
I'm sorry we couldn't celebrate tonight.
Thanks to mean old Mama.
What's even sadder is this rat's life.
Oh, your mean old Mama.
I mean, your mother.
What is she up to right now?
Oh, she's up all right.
Let's put her on the .
Okay, good when you're to come back again.
I respect you.
You must help us.
Always dreams of the future.
And I can imagine what we will see all through the light on Heaven's Day.
And the night that she breaks away is just Yo,
I thought this was a blind play through.
I don't know...
This game is just Mint Coated.
I don't know what else to tell you guys.
OK.
It's the end.
This game is a mint if your name shows up in the credits.
It's just extremely mint-coded, okay?
Oh, you need to stop doing this.
It's not funny anymore.
I'm scared.
I'm scared too.
Maybe this is the ghost trick all along.
Okay, so welcome back.
Thank you in hybrid.
Welcome back.
Stop reading.
I'm not reading.
Real Ace Attorney fan.
It's true.
Oh man.
Ghost to ghost communication.
My stubborn mother is kind of tied up at the moment.
Get me down.
She needs to be taught a lesson for causing us so much trouble.
Angelic Descent.
Welcome to membership.
Mint, are you the lamp?
No, Amelie.
Is it you?
Are you the baddie?
I'm the one who was wrong.
Hey, what's in the sand?
Is that the script?
You could have lived if you played this game within four minutes of your own death.
And you're right.
Could you tell your mother I'm sorry?
What do you have to be sorry about?
Can I have the lottery numbers?
If you're Shu Takumi, can we have another Edgeworth game?
I was just about to make a terrible mistake.
But it's all right now.
Oh my god, his face all of a sudden.
Oh, he's actually kind of handsome.
Oh, okay.
You're still young.
There's a lot I can't tell you right now.
The job of justice minister is very complicated, you see.
Yeah, he lost all of his wrinkles instantly.
Okay.
But just remember, you're always the most important thing to your mother and me.
Did you do something naughty to your mother?
If you did, I want you to apologize.
I don't think I did anything.
But okay, I'll apologize.
That's a good girl.
Okay, Papa.
Have a good night.
I love you.
I love you too, Amelie.
Have a good night, sweetheart.
And that was that.
Maybe I should call the police.
Uh, Mama?
I'm sorry.
My goodness, why the sudden change?
I guess I was wrong about you.
I didn't understand.
Oh, Amelie.
Yeah, and the fire department.
I thought all you ever did was write these weird novels.
That makes me a little sad.
Papa said the job of justice minister was complicated.
Yes, your father's job is very, very complicated.
And difficult.
That's why I couldn't talk to you about most of it.
If you're right...
But you're right.
I shouldn't treat you like such a little girl anymore.
You're growing up, after all.
And I promise to stop calling your novels weird and try to actually read...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't read them.
What?
Oh, maybe you'd better wait until you're a little older for that.
Okay.
So, Amelie, if you're feeling a little more charitable toward your old mama, do you think you could let me down now?
You know, I would love to do that.
But I'm just feeling too dizzy and sick right now.
Oh...
Tonight, on this holiest of nights, my deadline...
It looks like the only thing pressing on me will be this chandelier.
Here's to Papa and Mama's darling angel.
Ding!
That thing is so... it's so... what's the word?
It's so sturdy.
It's holding her up so well.
All of a sudden, everybody is getting along again.
It's such an abrupt change.
I can't understand it.
Is this what family is all about?
In any case...
The situation has changed dramatically now.
I just hope the mysteries of me can be cleared up as quickly as the furrows on the minister's brow.
I wish I was that chandelier.
Punpun, you keep... you keep... you keep dreaming, you know?
Never let go of that dream.
Think about how you want to be the chandelier in this very moment.
And never let go of that feeling.
Thank God.
If only...
If only I were the chandelier tightly... tightly grasping a grown woman's waist.
Her bosom too big to fit through.
Her bottom too big as well.
Just keep thinking about that as your dream.
Just keep thinking about it.
And never let go.
Because that...
is what dreams are made of.
I don't know where Camilla is.
At least now the justice minister's doubts are dispelled.
I think I'll go back to his office where everybody is waiting for the prison mat.
Uh-oh.
Don't tell me we got there and he already got picked up.
Never let go of the bosom or the bottom.
Be the chandelier.
I'll toast to that.
Amen!
Top and bottom's big because they're filled with our dreams.
Exactly, exactly, exactly.
Mint, I'm stuck in my dreams!
Dream.
Keep dreaming.
Don't let go of the dreams.
Just keep living.
Live.
And dream.
The minister's family now has their smiles and harmony back.
But Camilla is still in the hands of the kidnappers.
I decided to go back to the justice minister's office.
Oisha.
Surprisingly, the minister's brow is still just as furrowed as ever.
Quite unlike a father who has just learned his daughter is safe.
He seems to still be in the depths of despair.
The atmosphere in this room is very different now.
It seems to have an air of unfocused anxiety.
I get the feeling something big is about to happen.
I just found out that my daughter is safe.
I'd like to express my gratitude.
Thank you.
Thank you for my daughter's sake.
And for mine.
Thank you.
Oh, ha, hoo, hey.
No need to thank us, Mr. Minister.
It was nothing.
You didn't do anything.
What did he do?
But one question, I can't help but notice.
Your daughter is safe.
And yet, you still look unhappy.
How about a little smile for us?
Ahh.
Of course.
Worse, there is still the matter of the other kidnapping victim.
But is that really the only thing that troubles you, Mr. Minister?
Please, let me think in peace until the prison van arrives.
What?
No, no, no!
Come on, man!
I wonder if Lynn is at the park yet.
Until we get her report, I guess we'll just have to wait here.
This continued distress of the ministers...
Is there really something more to it, like the inspector in white said?
Yeah, let's see what he says now.
Oh, because also...
Is he probably getting blackmailed by the blue people or something, you know?
Hold on.
Hello, Justice Minister.
How about you finally admit I do exist?
That thank you I expressed.
That was meant for you.
You're a ghost, aren't you?
And you have the power to control and manipulate people, don't you?
No, I don't have that kind of power.
I can't control you.
Ghost?
We've actually known you, you know, for quite a while now.
But I had no idea they were the powers of the dead.
Of ghosts.
Known?
Wait, known about what?
We knew about the existence of somebody who could control others.
A manipulator?
What's this?
That's why your execution order caused me so much anguish, Detective Jowd.
Mr. Minister.
Why don't you just tell us everything you know?
Is that why they're in the special prison?
Is everybody in the special prison affected by these manipulating cases?
So they might be innocent, but like...
They were manipulated.
I suppose I should.
Thank you, Malia!
Thanks for the five gifted.
Thank you!
You need to hear it all.
All about the huge mistake this foolish man made.
Manipulator.
There are some cases in this country right now that are under attack.
A top -secret investigation!
Of course you wouldn't have known about them, Detective Jowd.
Right.
They don't share too much top-secret information with the inmates in prison.
There are three prisoners including you in the special prison you just escaped from.
All three cases have certain points in common.
They do, do they?
Tell us more.
I knew it!
The rock singer who leaked national secrets in his lyrics during a TV broadcast.
The curry-loving fellow who took the chief commissioner hostage at the Metro Police Department.
Neither of these men had a motive for their crime.
And both of their crimes were impossible.
Yeah!
Impossible.
The curry-lover had no way of knowing how to infiltrate the commissioner's office.
And the rock singer had no way of knowing the national secrets he leaked.
Sausage head.
The special investigation unit submitted an investigative report to me on them.
It concluded that these men's criminal acts were not of their own volition.
How could that be?
The theory the unit came up with was the existence of a manipulator.
A manipulator, huh?
Ghost that saves lives and ghost that kills wives.
That's when the special prison was established as a facility to research that theory.
It would make sense then why she has the sixth sense, right?
Because if they're working with the bad ghost...
If they're working with a bad ghost, she would have the ability to sense ghosts, you know?
Sorry, I was chewing.
That's when the special prison was established as a facility to research that theory.
Child's case.
Some unknown power has been at work.
These past several years, Inspector Cabanela has been studying these cases.
He has, has he?
Manipulating somebody into committing a criminal act.
According to the inspector...
Wow, Joshua!
Firmly grasped the ghost.
Thank you for the outcome so far!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Thank you so much!
I really appreciate it!
The first case of its kind was a locked room murder involving our nation's best detective.
Are you saying I was somehow manipulated?
Or are you trying to say I was manipulated somehow into shooting Alma?
I appreciate the theory, but unfortunately...
I don't recall being controlled by anybody.
It's just not possible to manipulate another's behavior like that.
My powers certainly don't work on living creatures.
That's what I thought when I first heard the theory, too.
However, I was seriously mistaken, and it proved to be a big mistake.
What?
Okay, the minister's mistake?
You mentioned a mistake.
Could you tell us about it?
I suppose everybody here has the right to know.
All right, fine.
I'll speak out.
Can you just... Inspector Cabanela is like sitting in this room in silence while they're probably all like...
Locked in in this conversation in their brain.
All right, fine.
I'll speak out loud so that Inspector Cabanela can hear this, too.
Oh!
Interesting, okay.
Everyone's using codecs.
It's the go-deck!
The ghost codec!
There's something I'd like the two of you to hear.
It's about a mistake I made.
Inspector Cabanela, when you first made that report about a manipulator, I'm afraid I didn't believe it at all.
Impossible, I thought.
Perfectly understandable, Mr. Minister.
But I was wrong.
That kind of power does exist.
And I...
I learned the truth of that first hand.
What's this?
A month ago, I signed the order to carry out Detective Jowd's execution.
However...
That act wasn't of my own volition.
I was being controlled.
What?
You never told me about this, Mr. Minister.
What's going on?
This document?
What am I doing?
No, I mustn't sign it!
Why is he clapping?
What's going on?
Wait, did he sign it?
Oh, no!
Wait, don't deliver that document!
Oh, I guess he just doesn't listen to you.
That's when it started.
That's when all of my fear, despair, and suffering began.
Oh my god, he must be so paranoid.
Fear, despair, and suffering.
At the time, it didn't even cross my mind that I had been manipulated.
And my memory of the event was only hazy at best.
Hmm, so the memory of being manipulated doesn't clearly remain, eh?
Signing execution orders is part of a justice minister's job.
At the time, I just thought my psyche was rebelling against the task.
Through this arm, I live.
But the next day, it dawned on me.
I remembered Inspector Cabanilla's report on the existence of a manipulator.
Oh...
As the Minister of Justice, I couldn't admit what had happened to me.
I only signed the execution order because I was being controlled.
Oh, sorry.
If something like that got out, this nation's judicial system would crumble.
Besides, I had no evidence to present that I had actually been controlled.
One month haunting, thank you!
So in the end, I couldn't admit to anybody what had happened.
Hmm, I suppose.
But it sounds like a bit of an excuse.
You should have at least told us, Mr. Minister.
You're lost.
Noir, thank you!
Sounds awfully familiar to the tale of someone eating cake with no memory of it, huh?
Um...
Uh...
Anyway...
Next question.
Psycho Ventus...
Oh my gosh, Joshua, thank you for the ping!
Thank you!
Cool guy, welcome back!
Yes.
Yes, I know.
I should have.
I was... running away from the problem.
Psycho Mantis...
His wife...
And then my wife found out I was worried about something.
Well, if you go around with an expression like that, I guess it's bound to happen.
I explained it to her.
She was dead set against the way I was handling it.
Oh, she has...
Whoa!
If you don't withdraw that order and tell everybody the truth immediately, I'm moving out!
Ooh.
She's a...
She's a feisty woman.
And then, with the kidnapping tonight...
With it thrust under my nose like that, I could make...
No longer deny my mistake.
What's this?
Some mysterious force has my wallet!
Evan, welcome back.
Sit down, thank you for the super chat.
This manipulator comes upon us from somewhere unsafe.
That's why I've been keeping my distance from everybody.
So that's why you've been telling people to stay back.
So there's somebody else besides me with the powers of the dead.
I'm fine with that.
After all, I already knew about a certain desk lamp.
Yeah...
What I'm not fine with is the fact that person can control and manipulate living creatures.
That's certainly not something I can do.
Yeah...
Apparently, different ghosts get different ghost tricks.
See, I just don't have the correct ghost trick, you guys.
I just don't have the correct ghost trick.
It couldn't be me.
But I never imagined that tonight, I would find out where this kind of power comes from.
Where it comes from.
Ghosts.
Inspector Cabanela.
This manipulator is a ghost.
A departed spirit.
A specter!
A spirit?
As a matter of fact, there's a ghost talking to us right now.
What?
What did you say?
Chao, don't tell me you can hear this ghost too?
I'd say the only person who can't hear him is you.
Spirit.
Ghost.
Gods.
Heaven.
Excuse me, Mr. Minister.
I suddenly have some urgent business to attend to.
That's kind of sussy, isn't it?
I'm being manipulated to send this super.
I can't control my actions.
To Chonky, no!
I recommend you think long and hard before making your final decision, sir.
There he goes, trotting away.
He didn't even dance.
Is that Lin?
Hold on, I'm eating.
This is Lin!
I'm at the park!
Uh-oh.
Lin's about to get kidnapped, isn't she?
Lin's about to get kidnapped.
We've been waiting to hear from you.
Have you found the evidence?
Well, the situation here is kind of difficult to explain.
Sissel, if you're there, come to the park immediately!
Uh-oh.
Well, somebody died!
It looks like your help is needed, Sissel.
This is a normal Super Chat.
I am not being manipulated.
That's something someone being manipulated wouldn't say.
Someone being manipulated would say, I'm being manipulated.
But Wolfwood, you're definitely not being manipulated.
Yeah, I guess so, huh?
Let's go to the park!
Meow, park.
Yippee!
I'm being manipulated.
I'm being, I'm being manipulated.
No, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
I think the Chonky is onto something.
Your ghost trick is making us send mint-colored Supas.
Help!
Lynn calls and I oblige.
I take off towards Temsika Park.
The place where, clearly, something big is taking place.
Stay clean!
Thank you for the Aqua Supa!
I am in full control of myself.
All my faculties are working without issue nor impediment.
The bank will not decline the payment request.
I will remember exactly what I've done with no regret.
There is no negative influence on my person at this moment.
I'm not playing King.
Thank you for the Aqua Supa!
That totally was not manipulated out of you.
Thank you!
The guards don't say anything.
They've been there all along for everything.
Are they deaf?
You know what?
Don't worry about them.
It's like the guards at, you know, the palace and stuff.
They're not allowed to, they're not allowed to, you know, interact.
It's like a...
It's like a person on a nature documentary.
You just watch from the distance.
Fukuro, thanks for the five gifted!
Stupid shark!
It's happening here too!
Thank you!
There must be a manipulator on every turn.
Every time I turn on my gacha.
Oh, probably.
Oh my gosh, say that!
Am I many pull lady?
No, no, I guess it works.
Min gacha or something.
Man, man, many, many pull lady.
I don't know that word.
Strange, too strange.
I'm sorry.
Sorry, I think I've missed so many words since I've been dead.
You know, my memory is kind of, you know.
Hayden, thanks for the five gifted!
All right, let's go to Temsik Park, everybody.
The manipulator.
The person whose very existence sheds new light on everything.
Detective Joud's crime.
The execution orders.
And even my own death.
Could it be?
Could Lin have been manipulated into shooting me?
I completely forgot that was an element!
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh, thank you guys for all the super chats.
Thank you!
Thank you guys.
That song was called To Nothingness?
How many?
What chapter?
What are we on?
I can't remember.
Thirteen now?
Fourteen!
Fourteen out of...
Out of eighteen, right?
I wonder if I should just power through today.
A system sending a message while resisting?
I'm being manipulated!
No, no, no.
You wanted to send that!
Nice progress.
Hmm.
Don't you have something big tomorrow?
Do I?
I don't think so.
Let me check my calendar.
Ope.
I don't know what I just did.
Uh, no!
Wait.
Tomorrow's Wednesday.
Okay.
The rest is long.
Hmm.
If I do four more chapters, one hour each about...
It'll be four more hours.
What time is it?
Hmm.
It might be into the middle of the night.
After this chapter is the best stopping point.
Okay.
I'm not being manipulated.
Ah!
Wait until after this chapter if you want to decide to finish.
The upcoming puzzle is probably the hardest in the game.
Oh!
Okay.
All right.
Cool.
Then we'll decide for this puzzle after.
Okay.
Ghosted Nose.
What's the...?
Boo!
What kind of stationery does a ghost use?
Ghosted Nose!
Boo!
Okay.
Maybe we'll do this chapter and then we'll save it for tomorrow?
I could probably finish it tomorrow then.
Temsik Park.
The site of the Little Lady Camilla's abduction tonight and the place where an important piece A piece of evidence.
The music box was hidden.
Oh wow, we're on the other side.
I wonder why our lady detective is looking so dejected.
At least she isn't dead.
But what did she find?
Oh!
It's the chicken!
It's the... it's the...
Kitchen?
Chicken?
Chicken Kitchen Man!
What's he doing here?
A little late?
It's already ice cold!
Oh my god, this guy sucks.
Oh, we have to wait for him to get closer to us.
There we go.
Okay.
Swing harder!
Basketball?
Oh, there's a basketball in there.
Globe.
Boot.
Leaflet.
Love letter?
Umbrella.
Rugby.
Spin?
Ball.
Wait, there we go.
Seesaw.
Ooh, I got this thing spinning pretty fast.
I didn't even put much effort into it.
This is quite a bit of power and speed for a piece of playground equipment.
You can just imagine all the poor kids who get sent flying all over the park.
That's what I'm thinking.
Hello, I'm here!
Wait!
Oh, I saw it!
I saw a dead person!
Oh, they were on the far left!
Oh, there you are, Sissel.
From your dejected expression, I gather, you didn't find what you were looking for.
Right, I can't find the music box anywhere.
But I found something else instead.
Something horrible.
Horrible?
What is it?
A dead body!
Oh!
There, in the grass.
You'd better see for yourself.
Looks like a dead body!
I nearly died when I saw it.
I suppose now that we've found it, we can't just leave it there, can we?
Nope, I suppose not.
Mascot...
Alright, let's make connection!
Stop reading ahead!
What do you mean?
Oh, it's this guy!
I forgot about him!
Stop the park from being turned into a housing site!
Protect the park!
The Rock of the Gods!
You there!
You're talking to me, aren't you?
I have some leaflets for you!
Leaflets I know you'll be very interested in!
I urge you to peruse it thoroughly!
Examine it in detail!
Never mind that right now.
Do you remember your name?
My name...
What does my name matter when there are more important things to worry about?
He speaks for the Rocks...
Okay...
Come now and study these tracks with me, my brother!
Come and learn about the Rock of the Gods with me!
The night is no longer young.
As a matter of fact, daybreak is approaching.
But we are young!
It only just turned twelve!
Look, I don't have time to get involved in your way of life.
But I am interested about your way of death.
So let's go back.
Back to four minutes before your death.
Oh my god, it's been a while since we've... since we've done a...
Like this whole stream, we haven't... we haven't gone back in time.
I think he got crushed by the... by the gods.
Wait, this is a long time ago.
And so I made up my mind.
I resolved to live here in the park and defend it.
Okay...
And what does that have to do with this Rock of the Gods you mentioned?
Yeah, 8.25 p.m.
You still don't appear to understand.
No wonder this one is probably hard.
It's written quite clearly in the fourth leaflet.
In great detail.
Excuse me, but I have to use the restroom.
Oh, this is when she gets kidnapped.
I'm coming!
Just hold on!
I'll be right there!
I'm looking in the door and get me...
Oh, oh, he took it!
Yes, my dear.
I'll ever so gently nab her and come right back to your side.
Dang it, Shaggy.
It's all your fault.
Oh, he's gonna, like, hit the lever, isn't he?
Good evening, young lady.
Won't you come with me?
Ew!
Oh, my God, sorry.
Oh!
Shaggy!
Oh, my God.
Wait, that guy...
Wait, the hippie is actually wearing Shaggy's clothes.
Oh, guys, what do I do?
What should I do?
I have to do something.
Is this where she died?
Oh, my God, wait.
We have to ghost trick?
We have to ghost trick to stop someone else's ghost trick?
No way!
What in the world just happened?
Oh, that's Mino.
Mino?
Mino, the mascot, the symbol of Temsik Park.
Forget about the name of that big creepy lump of concrete.
Talking about the way it changed direction.
Did you see that?
Yes, yes, I did.
And we witnessed it with our own eyes.
The power of the Rock of the Gods.
That was the power of the Gods.
The power of the Gods saved that little girl.
And then that same power very deliberately crushed her.
And it crushed you instead?
You gotta ghost the ghost trick.
Yes, yes, precisely.
That is called the mischief of the Gods.
This is how Shaggy's parents met.
What?
That couldn't have been a ghost trick.
No ghost trick could change the direction of something that heavy in mid-air.
But wait a minute.
What if there was somebody with much greater powers than me?
There's another flame besides mine.
Oh, is that the flame of a god, is it?
But hold on.
Your spirit is a flame too, isn't it?
Yeah, so?
Pardon me, but are you a god?
I knew he was gonna ask that.
Because I read the script.
I sincerely doubt it.
Brother!
At the last minute, that big lump of concrete made a huge swing to one side.
That was probably that flame's doing.
Who could it be?
It's not a missile, is it?
I definitely believe it's either a god or somebody god related.
Maybe I'd better try talking to this person.
Here we go.
What the?
This person with much greater powers than me.
It's...
Missile?
You?
Hey!
Sizzle!
It's Missile!
Wait, does that mean Missile's dead?
Uh-oh.
Oh my, it's...
Missile!
You look well for being dead.
Did you see?
Did you see what I did?
I did it!
I tried really hard and I did it!
I saved Miss Camilla!
What is that?
Are you telling me I was done in by a puppy dog?
Sizzle, what's going on?
How did you get the powers of the dead?
I'm glad you asked!
After Miss Camilla went out and you left?
Run, run, run, Missile!
Yeah, Missile's back, Missile!
Missile, Missile!
I worked like crazy to make my own path and I did it!
Missile!
Smart dog.
And then I followed Miss Camilla out into the big wide world!
Oh my god, this is where it happened.
And then, here at this park, I found her at last!
Yes, you guessed it, I barked!
You bet I did!
And I went running after her too!
Woof, woof!
And then I guess I died.
Missile...
Missile!
Missile, Missile!
And then, I was unconscious for a little while.
Shaggy killed Missile.
Missile...
Missile!
I can't tell you how surprised I was, but I bet you understand, right?
Better than probably anybody else could.
And then I remembered what you did for me, how you saved me.
So, you went back, right?
Back to four minutes before...
Wait, that means Camilla and Missile are able to communicate with each other.
Shaggy, you will never be forgiven.
I hope... I hope... I hope you never...
I hope the blue lady never smiles at you ever again.
You went back, right?
Back to four minutes before the little lady's death.
You bet I did!
Yeah, and that's why Camilla has a core!
Yes, my dear Oliver, so gently nab her...
We've heard this before.
And he says...
Come with me.
Awful.
I hate you, Shaggy.
Now's my chance!
I thought I saw the core!
Oh, now's my chance, I thought.
I saw the core!
I don't know, it looks pretty far.
I stretched out my paw towards the core!
Oh wow, I felt out that moment.
I'd love for you to be able to feel it too.
Go ahead, Sissel.
Go ahead and try it for yourself.
Whoa!
I can't believe it.
How could you connect over such a great distance?
Well, they don't call me Missile for nothing.
And so, then you manipulated that Mino thing and threw it aside.
Right on top of my head.
Well, no actually.
Hm?
I can't manipulate things like you can, Sissel.
You can't?
And how did you...
I don't know what to... I didn't know what to do!
Then I happened to see something out of the corner of my eye.
And it had a core too!
A single leaf hanging from the tree!
Wait...
So, is Missile's ghost powers like...
Able to connect a thing?
So it kind of like swung?
Like his power is this...
He like...
Swapping?
Oh, maybe swapping.
Oh, I don't know.
Let's see.
I thought he like had it swing over there.
I tried reaching out to the leaf!
What in the world?
I can't manipulate things.
But apparently...
Oh, he swapped them!
As long as the two things have the same shape that...
Oh...
That is so...
Specific.
Swap things with the same shape...
Go ahead and try it!
First swap!
So now...
That's incredible!
Oh my gosh.
This late into the game they're introducing a new game mechanic?
No wonder this puzzle is so difficult.
So that's how you saved your mistress, is it?
And that's how I became caught up in this, is it?
I'm very sorry!
My powers were too meager!
Meager...
Because you see...
I saw one more...
I happened to notice one more core!
There was something...
With the exact same shape stuck in the branches of a tree!
You're right!
It's the rugby ball.
If Mino could be swapped again with that...
Then disaster wouldn't have to...
Have to rain down on my head.
But what is that thing?
It's too big to be a leaf.
Whatever it is, I'd much prefer it on my head than Mino.
So why didn't you swap them, Missile?
It's too far.
Couldn't.
I could stretch out my paw a little further than you can, Missile.
But this was just too far for me.
I couldn't reach.
Ta-da!
Now it's not a beehive.
It's a rugby ball.
Sorry.
I must admit, it's a fascinating spectacle of a death.
If I do say so myself.
I couldn't reach it.
Oh well.
I kept retrying over and over, seeing if there was anything I could do.
I bet there's something you can do now.
If we work together, you and me.
Cecil, you think so?
Wait, but then...
But then...
Can we...
Can we save Missile?
I don't plan on letting anybody die in front of me tonight.
Do you think you could help me?
Of course!
Naturally!
So we're going to drop that Mino thing in a different spot.
Okay, let's try it.
Let's go back again to four minutes before.
Wait, we have to save Missile.
I swear, if she goes back...
If we go back to the present and she's alive and everything and...
Oh wait, though.
No, because she'll have already been kidnapped.
But if Missile's just there lying in that...
In that poor...
In that poor ditch...
I'll be so sad.
Let's get started.
Four minutes from now, you'll swap Mino with the leaf.
And then you'll have to swap Mino with something else.
Something with the same shape.
Oh, I believe that's a rugby ball.
Okay, rugby ball, huh?
But with the rugby ball where it is now, Missile can't reach it.
So that means we have to move it closer somehow.
Looks like you and I will have to work together on this...
On that one, Missile.
Okay, I'm ready.
Whenever you want to use my swap trick...
Just press Z, R.
Okay.
Z, R.
That way you'll be able to control me.
And then if you press Z, R...
Control will come back to me.
Okay.
Let's try it.
Together we can stop Mino from hurting anybody.
Trick time.
Alright, Missile.
Your powers are the key this time.
Okay, I'm ready.
I can swap anything that has the same shape.
Just call on me if you want to...
If you find anything you want to try.
The best thing to do is to try and find a bunch of things and see how it goes.
Use Z, R.
Alright, let's head back.
Open.
Oh, wait.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, here he comes.
Here he comes.
Uh-oh.
Time is passing.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Um...
So can I swap the...
Let's see.
Z, R.
Oh, and he can move further too.
That's so crazy.
Okay.
Maybe swap the basketball and that.
Oh, wait.
But I'm in the bass...
I'm in the baseball.
They're the same shape.
Um...
I think we need to...
Uh...
Wait.
How do I swap them?
Oh, wait.
Uh...
Blah-blah-blah-blah-blah-blah.
Swap.
But does that do anything?
Because I'm still here.
That didn't really help me.
Hold
on.
Oh, now it's too heavy.
Maybe because of the swap I made.
I guess the little ball is about all the weight I can handle.
Okay.
Let's go ghost.
Z, R.
Swap them back.
Let's swap the...
Um...
Tire?
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
Uh...
We'll stay here.
Z, R.
Swap.
Oh, wait.
No.
Hmm...
Okay.
Let's just see what else there...
Oh, my God.
He's just there.
There's also the love letter.
Look at this funny flattened ball.
It's the same shape as that horrible Mino.
That's too far to swap from here.
Even this ball is starting to look horrible to me.
We have to find a way to get it closer.
Lock it down from the tree, I say.
Oh, my God.
There must be something we can do.
Time is passing.
And then he flies all his things around.
Oh, man.
This is so tricky.
Hmm...
You're in the seesaw, aren't you?
Uh...
Yes.
Okay.
I can reach this.
So, what if I do this?
Swap.
And then...
Z, R.
Swap.
And then...
Okay.
That should be it.
Then we...
Uh...
Oh.
We need the seesaw to move back.
Oh, my gosh.
Please.
Move.
There we go.
And we go...
Oh, there we go.
No!
Ah!
Oh!
Okay.
Uh...
Maybe...
Oh, maybe we have it so he doesn't...
Oh!
What do you think of my lightning fast pace?
I wish he wouldn't knock it off.
I wish he would knock it off.
That's what I think.
We don't have time to prepare.
I think we're gonna have to find a way to stop him from running.
So...
Uh...
Maybe we stop him from using the thing.
The seesaw.
The swing.
Those things.
Precisely.
Except there are one more piece of equipment I...
To be exact.
Stop him with the equipment, eh?
Maybe I should rethink things here.
Well, hold on.
I'm still trying to...
Get over here.
Talk?
Why am I talking?
Oh, no!
Wait!
Oh, I forgot.
Missile was in the baseball.
This is so confusing.
That funny flattened ball is still in the tree.
I know.
There isn't much more time.
I wonder if maybe the...
Well, I don't think...
Knocking the...
I don't think knocking the rugby ball...
With, like, a basketball...
I don't think getting it on the ground is helpful.
I have to find a way somehow.
Okay.
You move there.
Oh, I'm still too short.
Okay.
And the swing.
We can't make it.
Oh!
This one's really hard!
Okay.
Ha!
Oh!
Um...
I feel like we need the tire...
Oh!
The tire needs to go either in here to make it too heavy for him to spin around or on here to make it so he can't...
He can't lift up.
Hmm...
But it's also timing because we need him to be on the swing so that we can...
Well, do we need to connect the...
Connect to the swing?
Maybe we don't.
Oh!
This one's tricky.
The balls are very important for the puzzle.
Yeah, I can tell.
I've gathered that much.
Because...
Do I stop him from getting over here, like they said?
Or do I get the rugby ball out of the tree?
Is the question.
Hmm...
I think you missed your chance at this point.
I agree.
No, I think...
I think so too.
But...
I think I'm still trying to cook a little bit.
I'm trying to...
I'm trying to think...
It's probably easier to just do though, you know?
Because I can't even get over here.
Yeah!
So I think it has to be...
Oh!
Unless...
Okay.
I'm possessing a ball.
Well...
Hmm...
I have to be able to possess a ball...
I think.
To be able to...
When it gets launched in the air...
Right?
I think I have to possess...
Something.
Maybe the basketball.
Okay.
I'm just gonna restart.
And we'll try something.
I'm gonna be swapping the balls a little bit.
Oh man!
Okay.
Here we go!
Open!
Sesame!
If I...
May backseat for a moment...
I would advise simply solving the puzzle.
Oh!
Thank you!
You're so right!
You are so right!
Where does the tire go?
Oh!
Mom, mom, mom, mom, mom, mom, mom...
And we have to stop him from running...
But I think he'll still try to spin.
So...
Let's...
Put the tire...
Oh no!
Let's...
Let's stay in the lid.
Okay.
Let's swap the tire...
The baseball...
We'll swap these.
And then...
The tire...
I'm gonna swap...
Hello?
Why can't I swap it?
Oh, I'm silly.
There we go.
Okay, I don't know why it was getting into me.
Okay, now I'm gonna swap these two.
Okay, I'm gonna try that.
And these two.
There we go.
Okay, let's attempt this.
Oh, and now you get out of there.
We're just gonna put you here, I guess.
And then we're gonna put you...
in the basketball.
Oh shoot, that's right!
It's too heavy!
Thank you,
thank you!
Sebastian, welcome to membership!
Ah, that's right!
That's right, that's right!
Okay, maybe I have to...
swap and then be fast about it.
Oh, no, no, no, no!
Uh-oh, uh-oh!
Uh-oh!
Okay.
Uh, uh, move?
Move?
Ah!
Okay.
No, no, no.
No, no, no!
There we go, there we go.
Swap.
Okay.
CR.
There we go.
Okay, okay, okay.
Here you come already.
I swear to myself not to repeat my mistakes.
Mistakes?
When somebody's in trouble, you should lend them a hand.
Otherwise, you'll definitely regret it.
And now the recklessness of youth has taken over, giving me lightning-fast speed.
Mmm, I've been thinking.
If we could stop this man from running, maybe he wouldn't get squished.
It won't be easy to stop me once the recklessness of youth has taken over.
Stop him, eh?
Okay, so maybe now things are heavy enough.
Right?
Okay.
He's not going so fast.
I think.
Ah!
Oh no!
No!
I thought I would be able to...
Oh...
I thought I'd be able to move while I was launched.
But I couldn't move.
Now I'm stuck.
Ah...
Okay.
Well, there was an attempt.
There was an attempt.
Time to throw in the trowel.
Yes.
Okay, let's retry.
Hmm...
Maybe the tire needs to be on here then.
There.
Oh!
No!
Oh my goodness.
What?
Why?
Remember that your goal is to swap the statue with the ball.
Not to stop him.
I get that.
I just need...
I think when the baseball gets launched...
Like...
It just sucks when I get launched.
I can't ghost trick.
So when I'm in the air, I can't get up there.
You know?
And we can't do anything with the...
With the balloon.
I'm trying to think of any other shapes that are similar.
But like the umbrella...
Even when folded, it's not similar to anything else.
And we can't reach that.
No, please stop!
No!
Please let me...
You know what, Sissel?
Get out of the way.
You go here.
Okay.
Yeah, you go here.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna become the joker.
Please.
Please just switch!
Why isn't it working?
God!
Stop, please!
Oh my god.
Oh, thank god!
Holy moly.
Oh yeah.
We have to wait.
No, no, no.
Put you here.
We're just gonna readjust a few things.
Maybe...
Hmm...
Maybe because it spins so fast, we put the ball in there.
The baseball might launch!
Maybe it will launch from the globe.
He'll spin really fast.
It will launch from the globe.
And maybe it will hit the...
Hit the rugby ball.
And then we can do something from there.
Who knows?
But with the tire here...
Oh, wait.
I think I realized I need to...
Well, let's...
I think I messed up.
Okay, hold on.
I did all that work.
But I think I need to switch these guys again.
Whoa, what just happened?
Um...
Order of operations.
Wait.
Oh...
Can you spin the climbing frame fast when he's on?
Oh yeah.
We can try, right?
Hold on.
The order of operations...
Wait.
My brain hurts.
Oh...
Because I...
I want the ball...
Okay, hold on.
Okay, let's switch these back again.
No, please.
Okay.
There we go.
Switch.
Even though it took me so long.
To switch it before.
Cancel.
Go there.
Oh, oops.
There we go.
Okay.
My brain is hurting a little bit.
Okay, basketball here.
And now...
Switch.
Okay.
So let's try this.
And then...
Hope.
Wait, but how long do I...
Oh no.
It's too heavy to move.
I can't get over there.
Okay.
We're going to have to be the fastest in the west.
We'd gonna have to be the fastest in the west.
Oh wait.
Chris' not so.
I was going to be faster.
Ghost!
Ball!
Move!
Ghost!
This one took me a while.
Oh my god!
He's already on it!
I still can't.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
Shoot, shoot, shoot.
There we go.
Okay.
Spin!
Spin it!
Wow, I didn't see this coming.
Okay.
Don't you know about the first thing about the globe climber?
Even little children treat it with the respect it deserves.
They know that unless you spin it gently, there's no stopping it.
Yeah, it does look pretty dangerous.
Looks like I'm just destined to fly through the air like this for a while.
Hmm.
This just might buy us some time.
Maybe he'll just keep spinning around like that for a whole four minutes.
I'm sorry, but I don't think I would stand it for that long.
But anyway, at least we stopped him from running for a while.
Let's see what we can do while we have our chance.
Okay.
Wait, there's two boots?
Look at that.
There's two boots.
Okay, great.
Now...
Now we...
You go there.
Oh my gosh.
I can barely...
There we go.
Okay, we made it!
Alright, wrestle this.
Just like before.
Now we can get up here.
And we'll close the umbrella.
And now...
That was so close!
If it hit the ball, it would have knocked it down.
Is that all this umbrella can be used for?
For knocking the rugby ball down?
Don't forget about my powers!
Don't forget about my recklessness of youth!
Open it up.
Uh-oh.
Time is passing!
Did you see the seesaw?
I guess the tire is too heavy to get that much height.
I wouldn't have been surprised if it launched me into the air.
The tire does have quite a bit of weight to it.
No matter how heavy it is, I can still swap it.
Wait, so maybe it shouldn't have been the tire.
Maybe we need him to jump into the air and flip the umbrella.
Or something.
Can he go into the rugby and drop it manually?
No, unfortunately.
Unfortunately, we cannot.
I think I have to restart though.
It took so long to get here though.
Basketball did a perfect arc before.
Now did it.
The b-ball.
Okay.
So we need to move the...
We need to move...
The...
Baseball...
Wait, no.
But we still need the baseball in here.
So we're just swapping the baseball and the basketball then.
Is that it?
We don't have to worry about the tire?
Thank you!
I
think I have to reset.
I think I've already missed my chance.
I think if by the time he's there, it's not completed.
It's not good.
I think...
I think I'm not good.
Right?
You have everything you need?
It's just execution.
I mean, I always had everything I needed.
Okay.
I'm gonna just retry.
I'm gonna retry with what we know now.
So...
Hmm.
Okay.
I think it was a super chat.
I don't know what it said though.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh.
Whoopsie.
Okay.
Here we go.
La, la, la.
Move the seesaw.
Into the seabow.
Seesaw go back down.
Here he comes.
Oh my gosh.
Already?
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Actually, you go here.
There.
Just a little bit of moving around a little bit.
Swap.
Okay.
And now we wait for him to spin so we can get on.
So he can get on.
Oh.
There we go.
Wrong.
Oh.
No.
Oh my gosh.
I'm pressing all the wrong buttons now.
Okay.
Now we spin.
Spin.
Restore!
Now.
The question is do I need the umbrella open or closed?
I'm not quite sure.
At this part.
I'm gonna try with it open.
I don't know why.
Oops, oops, my bad.
Okay.
Okay, now I'm gonna wait.
Oh.
Oh, what did that just do?
Okay.
Hahaha!
I so did not see that coming.
Oh, I never thought the umbrella would catch the ball.
Did you see that?
The tree branch, it shook a little.
I think I saw it shake too.
If only it shook a little more.
It would knock that terrible rugby ball down.
From this terrible tree!
Maybe it just needs a little more weight.
Sure we can do this, we just have to put our heads together.
Okay, well I'm doing all the thinking right now, Missile.
So I could really appreciate if you just...
Everything looks good so far, we just need one more step.
The tire...
Wait, do I have to restart?
Oh, wait!
I get it, I get it, I get it!
What do you think, Missile?
Okay, I think you can do it.
With the ball there, I think I can do it!
In just a few seconds, you'll swap me.
Mino with the leaf.
And then from there, you can swap Mino with one...
Mino, one more time!
The final moment is near, Missile, are you ready?
You bet!
Okay.
Don't mess it up.
I'm going ghost!
Okay.
I have to wait for it to start falling, don't I?
Yeah, I can't reach it.
I have to wait for it to start falling.
Okay, here we go.
Please don't make me have to do all this over again.
Please!
Oh, there we go, okay.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Okay.
Watch me sizzle!
Here I go!
Oh, it did it for me, that's so nice.
The finishing touches.
You can do it, Missile.
Swap Mino with that ball.
Swap.
Oh, okay.
I didn't have to time anything at all.
Nice.
Woohoo!
How's that?
My head has been spared.
Surely that was a try worthy of the gods.
Now Mino is right where he belongs.
Okay, we did it again, didn't we?
Didn't we?
Yeah, he's still in the same...
Same position.
Hahaha.
Nobody has to die.
Missile.
Good job, Missile and Minto.
Nice, Missile.
Missile and Minto.
Except for one brave little somebody.
Huh?
I'm talking about you, Missile.
Oh, me?
I guess you're right.
I'm still dead, aren't I?
So now let's go back and save your life.
Wait a minute.
What is it?
Now that I think about it...
I think I want to stay dead a little longer.
Oh, okay.
What?
When I was alive, I couldn't even help Miss Camilla when she was in trouble.
I want to be able to protect Miss Camilla.
And to do that, I need these powers I have now.
I see.
Perfectly understandable.
Even I wish I had powers like that.
Hey, we just saved you.
Don't wish your life away already.
Of course.
You're right.
You're such a good boy.
Okay, Missile.
Have it your way.
By the way, Mr. Reckless Youth.
There's a certain detective who needs that music box you found.
Oh, he's such a good boy.
Oh.
When we get back to the present time, could you give it to her?
Certainly.
You have my word.
Let's go back to the present.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He's still there.
And so Camilla ended up in the hands of the kidnappers.
We weren't able to change that part.
Wait, but we don't want her to have the music box.
Oh, no.
Wait.
We want...
Yeah, she threw the music box in there.
Now he's going to wake up.
Now Lin is going to get it.
That's right.
Ugh.
Missile is a diamond dog.
Lin listened to my story without saying anything.
I'm sorry.
I wish there was something else I could have done.
No, you did the best you could.
I'm sure she's all right after all.
After all, she has me.
Missile!
Missile?
Are you in there?
Missile!
Leave Miss Camilla to me!
I know I don't look much like...
Much...
Look...
Like...
Much right now.
But I'm sure I can help her.
Missile...
Bye, Missile!
Missile!
Oh, no!
I'm going to leave it up to Missile.
What are you talking about?
Go back to Kyojin!
But they're waiting for me...
Oh my god.
It kind of looks like Missile is being left up to the wind.
He's alive!
I have something to give to you.
Ta-down...
No, not!
Stop the park from make turn into a housing site.
Protect the park.
The rock of the gods.
Aren't you forgetting food?
Oh, pardon me, pardon me.
He's going on an adventure.
My apologies, this is for you!
Gonna need some more water soon.
You kept the music box safe, didn't you?
Thank you!
Not at all.
I was only doing what the Rock of the Gods...
would have wanted.
Does he have a concussion or something?
What's wrong with him?
Mega pocket.
What's the matter?
Cat got your tongue?
I think he thinks she's really pretty.
He's mesmerized...
by my beauty!
Hey!
The cat's not allowed to get your tongue!
Missiles averted.
Evade, evade!
Excuse me, but are you...
No, it couldn't be!
Have we met before?
Aren't you...
that little girl from that time?
I'll never forget it!
It was ten years ago in this park!
Shaggy!
Shaggy too!
Are you talking about...
Uh...
Here in this park, the gods surely control fate.
Today, ten years from that day, we meet once again.
If that isn't the power of the gods, then what else is it?
It could just be coincidence.
I can't believe it!
But apparently you know our lady detective here.
Could you tell us about it?
What happened ten years ago?
Yes, yes, of course!
I was actually about to do just that.
Rock of the gods.
What about this rock of the gods you keep mentioning?
Don't you know?
It's right there in front of us!
Me know?
Oh no, this place.
Missile!
Wait a minute.
You say gods, but do you mean dogs?
Of course not, don't be silly.
This is no time for ridiculous word games.
You are right.
You were standing just above the rock of the gods.
Wait, you were standing just above the rock of the gods now.
Take a good look at that monument.
Monument?
Rock of the gods, Temsec Park.
The rock of the... this took a turn that I did not expect at all.
I mean, we've been dealing with...
We've been dealing with ghosts and all sorts of supernatural stuff.
But I did not... I don't know...
I don't... I did not expect something like this.
The rock is buried in the ground right there.
It's been there these ten years.
Ever since that day it flew down from the heavens and showed us a miracle.
A miracle?
So this rock you've been talking about...
is a meteorite.
Precisely.
It's not a... it's not a rock.
It's not a...
it's not a rock.
Wait, it's the opposite.
It's not a boulder.
It's a rock.
It dropped from the sky on that day ten years ago.
Yes, of course.
Surely you know all about it.
Me?
Wait, so did the...
Did the rock, like, strike the guy?
So the detective didn't actually shoot and kill the person?
That day I just happened to be passing through this park.
I had no idea that day would change my destiny.
The sun was going down and through the gloom...
I heard the scream of a little girl.
Now just calm down and drop that weapon.
Stay back.
If you come any closer, I'll shoot her.
Oh my god.
That's not Cabanela, is it?
No.
No, no, because the guy died.
But look at that stance.
It looks very skinny and tall.
I peeked out fearfully from the bushes.
And saw some shadowy figures.
I didn't see the face of the criminal clearly.
I knew I should do something to help him.
But I couldn't move.
The tension was so thick, it was painful.
Just when I couldn't stand it any longer.
That's when it happened.
The sky suddenly burned bluish white.
I came crashing down on him.
When I crashed into the ground.
The meteorite gave off a shower of beautiful fragments.
Oh!
This is how we get the ghost trick.
If you die, where the meteorite has been, little pieces, That's why missiles are more powerful than ours.
Because I am a star!
That's why, because This missile died right next to the biggest chunk of the meteorite.
And maybe...
The guy that died by the meteor...
is the manipulator!
Stellar, stellar...
The meteorite gave off a shower of beautiful fragments.
Oh my god.
It's just like...
Oh my gosh, you know what it is?
It's just like the Shikan jewel from Inuyasha.
And then I saw it.
One of those beautiful fragments...
pierced into the criminal's back!
That's why he's the manipulator.
He's got the power of the rock!
The judgment of the gods was brought down on the park that day.
Ten years ago...
The little girl that was you...
was saved by the rock of the gods.
Why, I can't believe it!
The rock of the gods was given the name Temsik.
And still today...
It lies sleeping deep in the park's earth.
So...
Where we died, there was a fragment.
Maybe not a fragment.
Maybe what that guy...
The scientist in the park!
Wasn't he studying?
Wasn't he studying the...
The rocks?
He was studying the rocks in the...
In his little lab!
Maybe that's why we have the powers.
Temsik.
I never knew about this Temsik.
I always thought Detective Joud was the one who saved me.
You were very young then.
And you passed out from the shock of being taken hostage.
Of course you wouldn't remember.
But that's funny.
A huge incident like that should have caused quite a stir.
It's strange you never heard of it, Lin.
It is, isn't it?
But now I think about it.
I remember I didn't want to think about what happened.
I avoided the news and I never came back to this park again.
That's why I didn't know anything about it.
Whoa...
The meteorite was named Temsik after the...
After the name of this park that it fell in.
And then the Rock of the Gods was forgotten.
Now an awful thing is happening.
They're talking about turning the park into a housing site.
I'll never forget the miracle I witnessed that day.
And so I've taken up residence in this park and I'm trying to appeal to the people.
Protect the park!
Protect the Rock of the Gods!
That is my mission!
What's a kismet?
I keep seeing people saying that.
What is that?
I see.
The real mystery is how old is this guy.
I was thinking that too.
Oh, it means fate.
I see, I see.
I'm taking you with me, missile.
Fragment.
So ten years ago, the little girl that was Lin wasn't aware of the meteorite.
I get that.
But Detective Jowd, on the other hand...
There's no way he didn't know about this Temsik thing.
And if he knew...
Then the man died.
I took his life.
What was that confession of his all about?
I think Detective Jowd is just stupid.
I think kismet means Jaeger.
Jowd Hunter is his real name.
If kismet equals fate, Temsik equals reversed fate.
I like that!
Oh, that's so big brain.
Because we're reversing their fates.
That's so cool.
Yeah.
Detective Jowd.
Like, what the hell?
Why are you always like...
Yeah, I killed this guy.
No, you didn't.
And also...
Oh, yeah, I killed the wife.
No, you didn't.
What is the point of being the hero in this situation?
What was that confession of his all about?
Tell me all the others about the movie.
It's a little...
The gaming industry is really interesting.
There are things I learned from this movie.
Finally, the discussion for this under maidamara o Morgan.
I played.
It means sometimes the king is killed for the princess Many times in the past.
Yeah.
Kleff talk!
Cicel is on a pond when a pebble is dropped in.
With every answer I get, I learn about a new mystery.
Will I be able to break the chain of mysteries before dawn?
The biggest thing...
The biggest thing is...
Still don't know who Cicel is.
I tried cooking before, and I was way off, I think.
So I'm... I'm still... I'm still...
You know, I'm trying not to think too much about it.
Trying to just see how it plays out.
Anyway, now that we have the evidence we need, we decided to meet up again at the minister's office.
Besides, there are a few things I wanted to ask Detective Jowd.
We are way off to find out who we are?
We're here!
Oh my gosh!
We found the music box, Detective Jowd!
Good job, Lin.
I knew you would.
Once everything has been resolved, I had wanted you to give this to him.
Him?
You mean Inspector Cabanela, right?
I don't suppose he'll ever forgive me.
Detective Jowd...
Now then, let's get this thing open.
There's a certain knack to doing it, you know.
Okay.
Oh, you just gotta pull it open.
See?
Calls that a knack?
More like brute strength to me.
Oh my...
It's the Hammer Space!
Real.
You should find scorch marks on the grip.
Scorch marks?
When Camilla built her contraption, she used a special kind of string.
Yeah, don't look down the barrel!
What's wrong with you?
It's a kind of magician's use.
It burns up in an instant and disappears.
Why would little Camilla use something like that?
I don't know.
Maybe because she's a detective's daughter.
Not leaving any evidence behind and all that.
In the case report, there was mentions of some scorch marks.
On what?
Oh, on the walls, I'm guessing.
When it happened, Camilla was watching from her hiding space.
Revolver Jowd.
Revolver Jowd?
She saw the flame run to the gun, something she naturally didn't include in her design.
I took the gun out of the frame and replaced it with a picture.
If you remove the picture, you should find scorch marks behind it on the frame too.
And those marks should match up with the ones on the gun.
In other words, it proves the contraption existed there in that room that day.
Hmm...
And it didn't work the way your little girl intended, is that right?
Exactly.
Some cowardly culprit modified the design.
But that angle was never brought up in court.
And so as Justice Minister, I must call off the execution at this point.
Yippee!
I knew I was right.
It wasn't Detective Jowd.
Now we can finally prove that.
Thank goodness.
Thank you, Lin.
In those eyes of yours, I see the eyes of that little girl from ten years ago.
Cecil...
If you hadn't come to my cell tonight, I would be gone by now, without ever having known any of this.
This is what I deserve.
That's what I told myself these past five years.
But things are different now.
Thanks to you, my eyes have finally been opened.
Tonight.
I've come into contact with a lot of people's lives and got involved in their fates.
Yeah, don't I deserve to know who I am now?
The only reason I was doing that was to regain my own lost memory.
But things are different now.
We're connected to each other somehow.
I just know it.
That's why I need to ask you a few more questions.
In order to find the truth about us.
Yeah, we gotta investigate the real mystery now.
Fair enough.
Fire away.
Sorry, I'm like so invested in this now.
Let's check out the manipulator.
Hold on, I'm taking a sippy.
My throat is getting so dry.
Okay.
Yeah, I think I will stop after this just because my throat is like...
I've been talking so much today.
Cecil told me all about it, Detective Jowd.
About the manipulator.
Yes, and it looks like this manipulator really did a number on the minister too.
Please don't pick on the minister.
If he dies again, I'm the one who has to save him.
Cecil, do you think...
Do you think that's what happened to me too?
What are you talking about, Lin?
Yeah, I think so.
Don't tell me...
You were manipulated too?
There was always a part of me that just couldn't believe it.
That image of the one who shot me.
But now I see the possibility of a new explanation.
But...
Who is it?
And why did they do it?
Camilla's contraption.
That contraption was a birthday surprise for Camilla's mother, wasn't it?
That's right.
Something's been bothering me about it.
I feel like I know that device from somewhere.
Oh, she finally realized.
No surprise there.
You lost your life once tonight because of that machine.
Right, I knew it.
See, Detective Jowd?
No, I'm afraid I don't see.
Detective Jowd is a great detective if he walks up to a crime scene and says he did it technically.
He solved it.
And he gets the credit.
That's so true.
He has a spotless record.
It was me.
Flashback.
I told Detective Jowd about it.
Told him about seeing the exact same contraption tonight in a completely different place.
That's very strange indeed.
I was like thinking for a second.
I was like, how did...
Why would she think to know this?
Like, or rather...
Why did they do it?
They were doing a little silly.
Rather, I was thinking, why does the...
Why did the scientist guy know about it?
And...
I'm...
You know...
Part of me is just like, is he a bad guy and told her how to make it and then knew how to manipulate it?
Um...
So that it would be...
It would be...
Lethal?
Hmm...
Yeah, or the scientist was investigating.
Obviously, like, that's, you know...
The other half.
But...
Hmm...
That's very strange indeed.
A junkyard on the edge of town.
I've never even heard of the place.
And what's more, I've never told a single soul about that contraption.
You haven't?
Hmm...
That old pigeon guy.
Who in the world is he?
Yeah!
Temsik.
Detective Jowd, you must have heard this name before.
The meteorite that fell in the park ten years ago.
You were there.
So you found out about that, did you?
I heard that meteorite saved little Lin's life.
And then you took the credit!
That's right.
I couldn't do anything to help Lin that day.
But in that case, I don't get it.
If it's true, doesn't it mean you didn't steal somebody's life away?
What are you talking about?
Detective Jowd, you told me that ten years ago.
The person who killed the perpetrator in the park was you.
What?
But it was the meteorite!
Yeah, you weirdo.
I wasn't lying.
Also, this is totally unrelated, but it's been bothering me for so long.
Every time I see this portrait of Detective Jowd standing right here with the text blocking him...
His shirt reminds me of Osomatsu-san.
It reminds me of... not Karamatsu.
With the pink one.
It makes me think of it every time.
And it distracts me so much!
What's the pink one's name?
Ah...
Gosh, I can't remember.
Todomatsu!
I think of him every time.
Because of the little design.
On Totty!
It's so funny.
If anybody's wondering, I was a Jushi Matsu girl.
I wasn't lying.
I stole that man's life away.
No question about it.
It was entirely my fault.
I was just about to shoot him.
Ichimatsu was the sad guy, wasn't he?
I would have shot him in the next instant if the meteorite hadn't come.
At that point, I was already a murderer.
What?
That's not how that works.
That's not true!
You were trying to save me!
Lin, I'm sorry, but...
I don't think that's really it.
Huh?
The truth about ten years ago...
Uh-oh.
On that day ten years ago, a different incident happened in another place.
Another place?
Yes, in the police headquarters interrogation room.
This guy just can't stop lying!
The worst sort of incident.
A suspect who was being questioned escaped.
Wow, I didn't know about that.
I happened to be there in the detective division, so I joined the chase.
Fortunately, or I guess unfortunately, I was able to track him down alone in the park.
Hold it right there.
I fired a warning shot.
I wanted to catch him bad.
That warning shot made him panic.
At the time, I was a young and green detective, brandishing my sense of justice like a sword.
I made him panic and got you involved, Lin.
It was all my fault.
Detective Zhao...
All I could see was my target.
I couldn't even see you.
I'm so sorry, Lin.
So he didn't really have her interest in best... her safety in mind is what he's trying to say.
My sword is a tool of justice.
Well, you know what they say about that sword.
So the man who grabbed me died that day.
These last ten years, I've never forgotten his face.
And then a few years after that, when my wife Alma died in such a mysterious way, I thought it was fate my punishment was for what I'd done.
I mean, that would make sense.
Why the manipulator?
He went after Zhao's wife.
He's just like...
Revenge, baby!
Revenge!
I painted pictures in my cell.
Nothing but portraits of people's faces.
Size... 13.
Welcome to the membership.
Thank you!
All the faces of the many people I've met in my life and didn't want to forget.
Revengeance.
And tonight...
It was our face.
It was Cecil.
I finished my last portrait.
The final face I wanted to remember.
The final face.
The face of the man in the park that day.
Huh?
What?
Wait just one minute!
That can't be!
I saw that painting!
I saw the face you painted tonight!
What?
It was my face!
Are you telling me I was the man in the park that time?
That's right.
That face of yours is the face I saw 10 years ago.
The face of the man whose life I stole.
Of the man who was pronounced dead at the scene.
B-b-but hold on!
Detective Jowd...
That can't be true!
I just met Cecil for the first time tonight!
Did someone reverse our fate?
Somehow!
Maybe...
Did he think we were dead but then someone rever- And he died right in front of me!
By the way...
The name that I know of the man in the park that day by...
Isn't Cecil.
What?
From the first minute I laid eyes on you tonight...
I've been wondering...
Who in the world is this guy?
I...
Uh...
Mr. Minister.
Inspector Cabanela, where are you?
Oh, he's at the Pigeon Man.
Just be quiet and listen.
This is our demand!
You double-crosser, you!
I knew it!
Demand?
Our demand hasn't changed.
The execution must be done.
Unless he's being manipulated.
Once we've confirmed it's been carried out, we'll release the hostage.
What are you talking about, Inspector Cabanela?
And you know it wasn't my daughter who was abducted.
Does it really matter who the hostage is?
A laugh is a laugh.
Even if it's the daughter of a death row prisoner.
Once the criminal gets the punishment he deserves, the hostage will go free.
Carry out the execution immediately and wait for our call.
What is it, Mr. Minister?
You look paler than ever.
I think he's manipulated.
What in the world?
What is going on?
Inspector Cabanela!
Oh my god, what is going on?
For real?
The Rock of the Gods that fell from the sky ten years ago twisted the fates of many people and started a chain of tragic events.
And even now, the chain continues to grow even longer.
Inspector Cabanela's call proved that to us.
What is this?
And the greatest mystery of all has risen to the surface.
Who is this me I've been chasing all night?
The music is so awesome.
Who am I?
I'm Minto!
I'm even further from knowing than when I started.
Who am I?
Wow, it's 2.55 a.m.
Oh my goodness.
The linked past.
Save the data.
Stop the playing.
Wow!
Yeah, I think we'll finish it tomorrow.
We stopped.
We have three more.
16, 17, 18.
Oh no, wait.
We left on 14, right?
Hold on.
15, 16, 17, 18.
Wait.
Okay, so four.
One, two, three, four.
Four more.
Four more!
One, two, three, four.
And that'll be part five, which I think is a good like...
A good...
Number.
You wouldn't have been able to stop if you got any further.
I don't think so either.
We haven't seen the blue guy and his henchman from the beginning in a long time.
Looking forward to seeing how this ends.
Me too!
It's been... yeah.
I've been thinking about them.
Oh...
Arranged version.
Because there's originals, right?
Is this the original version?
And then...
Oh.
Oh, it is quite different, actually.
You're going to like the next level?
I'm... HO is the best one in the game.
I'm excited.
Okay.
So tomorrow, same time, same place.
We'll finish it up.
We'll get through the next four chapters.
We made a really good, great progress, though.
We went through one, two... We went through four chapters today, so...
Good job, everybody.
Good job.
I have a job interview on Friday.
I need luck.
Or I suppose a manipulator would help.
No, no, no.
If you got me in there, Mia, I'd be like...
I'd be like...
Oh.
The stream...
The OBS... something, something.
OBS stopped for a second.
YouTube died.
No, it was OBS.
Okay.
That means...
That means it's time for me to...
Quit it.
That means it's time for me to quit, I believe.
Well, guys...
Hold on.
I'm trying to bring up my chat again because YouTube was being kind of silly.
It always gets delayed after a certain amount of time.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
YouTube is dead for me.
Oh, boy.
YouTube...
YouTube live.
Here we go.
Okay.
Alright.
See you tomorrow, Minto.
Thank you, Alaric.
Thank you.
Thank you for the stream.
Thank you guys so much for joining me again today.
Tomorrow, we'll wrap up the mystery and... yeah.
I'm gonna go.
I'm actually... I was gonna talk for a bit but I think I'm gonna go because...
My throat is quite sore.
I'm gonna go take some of my...
Wait.
I think I'm out of my medicine.
I forgot to order more!
I'll get some more.
I'm at least gonna get some water so that I can...
Yeah.
But...
Saw something cool today on Twitter.
Umamusume Pretty Derby collab with...
Wait.
What?
There's a Top Gun collab with Umamusume?
Am I?
How did I miss this?
This is from like last week.
Oh my god.
How did I miss this?
That's so awesome.
Oh my god.
Brain rot is activated.
You were gone for a bit.
I guess so.
Oh my god.
Yo.
That's so crazy.
No way.
Oh my gosh.
Top Gun Maverick.
My beloved.
Wait.
It's two years and a week ago.
Oh my god.
You're right.
It says 2022.
Why did nobody ever tell me?
This page is probably gonna wonder why I retweeted their thing.
I guess it would make sense when the movie came out.
Right?
Because it wouldn't make sense.
It wouldn't make sense if it was now.
I was like...
It wouldn't make sense if it's like... I was like... Why is Top Gun doing a thing now?
Right?
The movie is a little old now.
It's still new in my heart.
I think that's why I didn't even question it.
I was like... I just watched it yesterday.
Alrighty.
Anyway.
Thank you guys again.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna go sleep.
Or...
Yeah.
I've got some stuff I need to do and then I'll sleep.
And then I'll make the waiting room for the finale.
And we will finish off Ghost Trick tomorrow.
And...
What's tomorrow?
Wednesday?
I will try and have a schedule out for this week.
It probably... I mean it's already late.
I'm really sorry.
I'm so late.
Sorry.
It's okay.
Devs please rerun.
Yeah.
Sorry for the late schedule.
It's just my brain was...
But I do have a collab this... this week I believe.
I believe I have a collab...
Going on...
Later on Thursday.
So...
You can look forward to that.
Maybe.
If you can't make a schedule this week, it's totally okay.
But I still need to.
I wanna... Because I still have Friday.
Saturday I have the truck event.
So I won't be streaming.
And then Sunday as well.
I'll need to make for Sunday.
Okay.
With Maus and Henya it leaked?
Who said it?
Who leaked?
Which one of them?
Which one of them leaked it?
Maus said it.
Okay.
But yeah.
Maus and Henya will be showing me around the Vishoujo Minecraft server.
So...
I was... I haven't gone into it yet.
I've been very nervous to go in because I'm scared of all the mods that they have and stuff.
But yeah.
Thank you for the raid.
I can't read it.
Savi.
Thank you Savi.
Okay.
Everybody.
Have a good night and I'll...
Sorry for the raiders.
Um...
Uh...
I uh...
I'm ending.
I'm so sleepy.
Okay.
Bye bye!
I'll see you later!
Who gifted?
Ducky!
Thanks for the gifted.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do-do.
Bye
-bye -bye.
Go with me!
Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye!
Oh, my God.
That's WB32.
Thank you for the...
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Oh, my God.
Thank you so much!